[Musique]
Nicolas Dupont bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Siew nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
sucement Nicolas Dupont
rant je suis président de Bou la France
j'ai 64 ans
et je suis au service de mon pays on a
décidé de vous faire venir ce soir pour
discuter de votre prisme de lecture de
votre côté souverainiste peut-être de
droite peut-être de gauche peut-être
souverainiste tout court français
français première question que je vais
vous poser c'est comment vous percevez
le changement de politique de Donald
Trump est-ce que c'est un couteau dans
le dos de l'Europe est-ce que c'est
l'opportunisme est-ce que c'est le le
prisme de lecture de Donald Trump versus
le prisme de lecture de Joe Biden et du
camp démocrate qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est une chance pour nous pour
les Français ça ne veut pas dire qu'on
doit s'aligner je suis Gauliste gaulien
plus exactement indépendantiste forcené
le droit des peuples à disposer d'eux
même et mais il faut saisir cette chance
puisqu'il remet en
cause le mondialisme
oligarchique il va peut-être y
substituer autre chose soyons prudents
mais utilisons ce moment de trouble pour
faire renatre la France c'est ça qui est
important
et il a sans doute plein
défaut il faut pas se tromper sur lui il
faut pas suivre bêtement mais en
revanche il faut profiter au moins de
l'offre de paix en Ukraine parce que ce
conflit en Ukraine c'est le suicide de
l'Europe c'est le suicide de Europe au
21e siècle voilà donc il y a un moment
on voit passer la paix c'est comme un
ballon de rugby pourquoi pourquoi c'est
le suicide parce que en fait les
Américains ont réussi avec le conflit en
Ukraine à séparer l'Europe occidentale
de la Russie et ce faisant ils ont ruiné
l'industrie allemande ils ont abîmé
l'industrie française italienne et et
parce que c'était la vieille idée de
brezenssk et des autres que si l'Europe
se faisait de l'Atlantique à l'Oural
elle pouvait compter au 21e siècle il
fallait la séparer et ils ont été pris à
leur propre piège ce qu' a compris Trump
et certains des siens c'est qu'en
poussant dans les bras de la Chine la
Russie ils affaiblissaient durablement
pas seulement l'Europe qu'il tuait mais
les États-Unis avec donc en fait il y a
ce que n'ont pas compris ces anes qui
nous gouverne et les idiots utiles qui
ont épousé tout ça c'est que l'avenir de
la la France est lié à l'alliance russe
je le dis j'ose le dire je suis un des
seuls à oser le dire ça veut pas dire
qu'on est naïf vis-àvis de Poutine ouais
c'est un peu foutu quand même là c'est
mal parti mais mais attendez tout ça va
être balayé parce que en tout cas c'est
le sens de mon combat moi si je me bats
c'est pour balayer tous ces tous ces
traîtres ce sont des traîtres qui devrai
être jugés en haut Cour de justice
pourquoi parce que ils trahissent la
France ils l'abîment ils la détruisent
et ils la font ils nous menacent de
disparition comme français c'est ils
abîment pas simplement le pays là je
sais pas si vous réalisez à quel point
le pays il est il est menacé de
disparition de fermer la boutique
c'estàdire c'est pas un déclin là c'est
c'est la volonté de détruire la France
et d'y substituer une espèce de de truc
européen qu'on appelle l'Europe mais qui
est pas l'Europe et et et de rendre
irréversible donc c'est là où c'est très
grave et c'est pour ça que je me suis à
nouveau levé je pensais pas repartir si
tôt
mais c'est pas possible de voir ça
c'està dire c'est pas possible de voir à
Emmanuel Macron qui a de la suite dans
les idées vouloir liquider
définitivement la France
profiter de des circonstances avec une
classe
politique
évanouie
tétanisée comme des lapins dans les
phares d'une voiture quoi c'est c'est
fou ce qui se passe donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai dit que jeercherai candidat
candidat indépendantiste parce que là
maintenant c'est la question de la
survie du pays et il faut que les
Français ouvrent les yeux
et merci de m'inviter parce que c'est
pas avec les médias traditionnels qu'on
va pouvoir faire ouvrir les yeux des
Français donc il faut il faut faire tout
ce qu'on peut chacun à sa place
pour pour réveiller les Français leur
âme c'est même plus une question
d'intérêt c'est leur âme c'est qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent devenir des esclaves
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent donc reprendre
le pouvoir ou devenir esclave ah c'est
c'est la question le comment vous
vous analyser la politique de réarmement
européenne de réarmement européen
alors c'est de la fouaise et en même
temps alors deux
choses la France pour moi n'est pas
concernée par cela pourquoi parce que la
France avait et a toujours même si ça a
été abîmé une force de dissuasion
nucléaire indépendante qui devrait
l'être il suffit de rester ce que nous
sommes de reprendre notre indépendance
sortir du commandement militaire intégré
comme je le
réclame mettre un peu plus de crédit il
faut passer à 2,5 % du PIB 3 % mais on y
arrivera pas tout de suite vu le
surendettement bon bref avec ou sans
l'entretien de la force nucléaire avec
si on arrive à 3 % du PIB avec une
stratégie les moyens les moyens ne
dépendent que de la stratégie par qu'on
n pas compris tous ces anânes j'entends
beaucoup de généraux vouloir refaire une
armée de champ de bataille de Gaulle
avait compris qu'avec la force de
dissuasion du faible au fort mais une
stratégie uniquement nationale
d'intérêts vitaux on pouvait se
dispenser d'une armée que nous n'avions
pas les moyens de nous offrir et qui en
plus était inutile donc c'est le génie
de Gaulle c'est d'avoir une stratégie
nucléaire adaptée à une stratégie de
défense et à des moyens bon en revanche
que les autres pays d'Europe se réarm
oui ils ont été les passagers
clandestins des américains pendant 50
ans d'ailleurs si les Allemands ont été
aussi forts économiquement c'est bien
parce qu'ils n'ont pas payé ce que les
Français ont payé bon donc moi je pense
qu'il faut bien dissocier les de 1 la
France doit rester indépendante avoir sa
stratégie pour elle-même pour pas être
entraînée
dans les guerres des autres et puis les
autres Européens qui se démerdent qui
s'armment davantage qu'il y ait ensuite
une coopération entre nous bien
évidemment hors autant à terme mais on
en est extrêmement loin parce que vous
avez bien compris la manipe Trump il
veut que les Européens payent plus mais
il veut toujours diriger parce que ils
vont pas lâcher la direction de l'OTAN
comme ça et donc c'est pour ça que nous
on doit surtout ne pas rentr dans cette
logique folle mais attention Macron
utilise ça pour en fait faire faire le
saut fédéral
irréversible qu'il cherche à mettre en
œuvre et ce saut fédéral irréversible
c'est la liquidation de la France ça
survie voilà pourquoi c'est vital on est
à une période extrêmement importante
vous connaissez la phrase de Lénine
laquelle il a des semaines qui valent
des décennies comment il y a des
semaines qui valent des décennies on est
dans ces semaines là travail travail et
encore travail c'était qui ça déjà ah ça
je sais plus revenons revenons à non
ouais l'analyse votre analyse du
réarmement quand on entend nos ministres
notre chef d'État les chefs de la
chanceillerie
européenne qui dit il
disent l'intérêt de l'Europe c'est que
la Russie perde parce que si la Russie
gagne l'Europe est
menacée pourquoi ça vous fait marrer
mais c'est tellement con mais pourquoi
parce que c'est faux on ne peut faire de
la politique c'est de Gaul je crois qu'
disait ça que sur des
réalités voir la Russie comme une menace
existentielle de la France c'est
mensonger totalement mensonger la Russie
peut être une menace de l'Ukraine ça
c'est sûr mais pas de la France et pas
de l'Europe c'est c'est ridicule pour
plein de raisons la première raison vous
la connaissez c'est que la Russie a eu
du mal à gagner 18 % du territoire
ukrainien et que c'est pas demain la
veille qu'elle va voir l'ensemble de
l'Ukraine et attaquer la Pologne et le
reste si elle avait fait la guerre façon
Amérique aplatir le pays et ensuite
envoyer les j
oui mais Russ ils ont fait ils ont fait
à l'inverse là ils ont envoyé J et puis
non mais là soyons clair on a voulu
faire enfin ils ont voulu faire c'est
qui il il les dirigeant l'oligarchie
atlantiste l'état profond américain
démocrate pour plein de raisons
euh plein de raisons on va dire prendre
attendez attendez attendez prenons dans
l'ordre parce que on a le temps je crois
c'est l'intérêt de cette émission donc
prenons dans l'ordre donc là c'est
l'intérêt c'est que le siège est très
confortable oui non mais c'est pas ça
l'intérêt c'est le temps vous savez le
temps c'est tout ça c'est le mérite de
l'âge euh c'est votre vanité qui parle
non c'est pas ma vanité c'est mon
expérience
euh donc je reprends vous posiez une
question pourquoi la Russie n'est pas
une menace existentielle parce que
d'abord la Russie n'a pas la capacité
même si Poutine le voulait il a déjà du
mal à prendre l'Ukraine on reparlera de
l'Ukraine après si je veux donc déjà
prendre et ensuite s'attaquer à l'OTAN à
la Pologne à l'OTAN c'est n'importe quoi
personne ne peut y croire donc ça veut
dire que si Macron dit ça
et si van derleyen dit ça que les États
Bales puissent le croire je comprends et
la Pologne à la rigueur cont tenu de
leur histoire douloureuse il faut savoir
être juste bon mais pour les autres il
n'y croi pas un instant donc c'est une
manœuvre de diversion pure pour faire
oublier les vraies menaces de la France
pour faire le saau fédéral qui liquide
la France qui est l'empêcheur de tourner
en rond la mondialisation et du l'avenir
donc c'est c'est un beau coup c'est vous
un ennemi imaginaire euh vous faites
peur à un pays VI quand même pas si
imaginaire que
ça mais tous les pays sont menaçants
dans ces conditions la Chine est-ce
qu'on peut faire une la Chine est
beaucoup plus menaçante excusez-moi la
Chine est beaucoup plus menaçante pour
les intérêts de
l'Europe que la Russie les États-Unis
sont menaçants économiquement est-ce
qu'on peut oui c'est la maorité est-ce
qu'on peut faire est-ce qu'on peut faire
une expérience de pensée vous et moi oui
en essayant d'être bienveillant avec
Macron oui ça ça ça a l'air de ça a
l'air de vous faire rigoler non
non qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
sur la guerre
économique si je vous dis que les Russes
et les Américains sont en train de faire
la la course aux e pâqu avec les
matières premières un peu partout il
sécuris il allit venir dans un instant
ils sécurisent leur sécurisent leur
approvisionnement les Russes sont assis
sur ce qu'il faut en terme de ressources
ils sont en train de neutraliser
l'Ukraine pour éviter que ça tombe dans
le le côté
utanesque l'Europe au milieu de tout ça
les États-Unis
devinent les États-Unis deviennent
béliqueux les Russes sont franchement
béliqueux nous on se retrouve au milieu
et on voit nos politiques et nos
chancelleries courir comme des canards
sans tête oui mais pourquoi ils court
parce qu'ils ont peut-être compris que
quand ça va se calmer l'Europe va se
retrouver au milieu du gay oui mais ce
qui est paradoxal dans ce que vous dites
NON essayez d'être bienveillant avec
Macron non non je suis pas bienveillant
non je peux pas être bienveillant c'est
un traître à la
nation c'est ce que vous dites ah mais
je le pense et pourquoi je tiens moi par
rapport aux autres qui sont évanouis là
pourquoi je tiens c'est parce que je
suis lucide c'est un traître à la nation
en 141 il serait au Ploton d'exécution
c'est votre point de vue mais c'est mon
point de vue je l'assume et je le
maintiens c'est un traître à la nation
il a liquidé des intérêts économiques
fondamentaux avec Alstom et tous les
autres on va pas revenir mais c'est
monstrueux ce qu'il a fait mettre un
petit mot il ah bah vous connaissez par
cœur l'histoire Alstom vous connaissez
par cœur l'histoire à Rabel vous
connaissez par cœur tous les éléments de
souveraineté fondamentaux ont été
liquidés premier point il a liquidé la
francophonie ça paraît que ce soir
personne n'en parle il a mis une
ministre wandz qui parle qui a supprimé
la langue française au
Rwanda comme secrétaire général de la
Francophonie il a fait pression sur les
chefs état francophone pour pas mettre
madame Jean qui était une Canadienne
enfin je vous passe les détails parce
que personne n'en parle jamais il a
liquidé euh il est en train de liquider
ils veut liquider la force de dissuasion
qui est l'assurance vie du pays et tous
ce beau monde continue leur petit jeu
politicar minable à l'Assemblée mais
c'est hallucinant bon je voilà premier
point donc je reviens sur la sur mon
obsession parce que
je il y a une chaîne de télé pour soutre
de ma gueule comme habitude euh qui a
ressorti une image de 2015 où j'étais en
Russie euh à l'invitation de la Doua la
seule fois où j été et où j'avais tenu
un discours sur l'Ukraine sur les
accords de Minsk et ils ont vu voulu me
montrer ça la l'antenne pour dire que
j'étais un agent russe bon j'étais aux
États-Unis j'étais enarique j'étais
partout j'ai jamais étaé l'agent de
personne et
euh et en fait je disais en 2015
exactement la même chose que j'ai dit en
2022 au lendemain de la guerre j'ai fait
une conférence de presse le 7 mars 2022
avec un plan de paix pour l'Ukraine que
je dis maintenant c'est-à-dire qu'on
pouvait éviter cette guerre qui avait un
moyen d'un compromis avec la Russie et
qu'on peut comprendre sans être un agent
russe que la Russie a besoin d'une
assurance que l'Ukraine ne sera pas dans
l'OTAN et ne sera pas un pistolet sur sa
tente si le Texas avait été abandonné
par un président
américain était devenu un État
indépendant en 1991
et que au fil des années depuis 2014 la
Chine avait installé des bases secrètes
et armé le Texas est-ce que vous croyez
que le les États-Unis auraient laissé
longtemps le Texas libre réarmer le
Texas le Texas est déjà armé non mais
réarmé le Texas contre les États-Unis je
prends le
parallèle moi j'ai rien pour la Russie
par rapport aux autres je dis simplement
faut comprendre l'istoire vous
objecter CRIM ils ont pris la Crimée
mais la Crimée elle a toujours été russe
arrê les conneries ils ont envoyé les
petits hommes verts non mais attendez
arrêtez le vous allez pas faire comme
les autres arrêter le fantasme la Crimée
a toujours été russe l'Ukraine a été à
moitié russe vous connaissez l'histoire
de l'Ukraine l'Ukraine c'est un tampon
c'est une zone tampon entre l'influence
slave et l'influence occidentale une
partie a été polonaise austrohongroise
l'Empire austro-hongrois la Pologne
s'est déplacée entre les mais personne
ne sait tout ça bon un jour j'ai
journaliste je fais une parenthèse mais
un journaliste d'une chaîne publique qui
savait même pas que l'Ukraine a été
créée en 91 ça même pas que c'était une
anci en 91 c'est pas une question de
naissance il a une question de culture
quand même bon bref l'Ukraine est une
zone de friction territoriale de
friction civilisationnelle de friction
culturelle quelle était ma question non
mais je vais revenir votre question
était bon je la connais sur est-ce que
c'est une menace russe est-ce qu'il y a
une menace russe donc je reviens
là-dessus c'était une zone de friction
moi je veux qu'on démine les choses
parce que l'intérêt de la France je
parle de la France l'intérêt de la
France et l'intérêt des Européens c'est
de ne pas créer une plie purulente au
cœur de l'Europe au moment où le 21e
siècle bascule dans un condominium
américanoch-chinois voilà avec une
pression en Afrique considérable et le
doublement de la population et en plus
une pression islamiste si on est assez
débile con abruti pour comprendre que
l'intérêt de la France au 21e siècle
pour assurer les 50 prochaines années
c'est de prioriser et de hiérarchiser
les menaces et que dans la hiérarchie
des menaces la Russie n'en est pas une
elle se trouve dans le top 3 dans le top
5 dans le top 5 dans le top 5 des
menaces dans la 5è menace peut-être
c'est quoi les trois premières menaces
pour vous la première menace pour moi
elle est il y a une menace de
colonisation de population de
remplacement
civilisationnelle avec une menace
islamiste premier point parce qu'on peut
revenir sur l'économie on vient pas sur
un changement de population il y a une
menace technologique américaine et
culturelle aussi et il y a une menace
économique
chinoise la souveraineté alimentaire
elle se trouve où là la souveraineté
alimentaire pour la France si la France
retrouvait une politique agricole
nationale comme je le propose à la
Suisse
notre souveraineté alimentaire est
assuré je parle de la France bon après
il y a les problèmes mondiaux il mais
donc je reviens attendez revenez dans
l'ordre parce que vous êtes tellement
intelligent ça change des émissions
d'habitude que j'ai besoin d'ordre vous
me demandiez est-ce que la Russie est
une menace je vous dis la Russie n'est
pas la première menace des dirigeants
machiavelliic veulent tuer la France et
l'achev et utilise cela qui sont ces
dirigeants selon vous ah bah Emmanuel
Macron est le plus brillant d'entre eux
pas parce qu'il est brillant mais parce
qu'il a gagné pouvez pas dire que notre
président de la
République est un traître ah si ah mais
non mais si c'est notre président à tout
le monde non arrêtez arrêtez arrêtez non
pas moi pas vous non mais vraiment vous
prenez pour un con je suis pas Marie Le
Pen bardez là pardonnez-moi non mais
là-dessus ça c'est gratuit c'est gratuit
c'est pas gentil oui mais il y a un
moment j'aimerais les voir réagir vous
savez il y a plus de déception de voir
des amis ne pas réagir des amis au sens
qui ont été des alliés politiques face
à un forfait qui sous nos yeux la
déclaration si vous voulez le discours
de mercredi à 3 semaines ou un mois je
sais plus de Macron sur la guerre en
Ukraine était un discours tellement fou
de démence
intégrale j'ai même pas compris comment
il y a pas eu une réaction
d'autodéfense de la classe politique
française pour dire stop mais mettez-le
internez-le alors non mais c'est pour ça
que j'ai fait cette vous avez raison
c'était une c'était une boutade
gratuite attendez je finis il y a une
exaspération que j'ai sur l'apathie de
la classe politique à un moment
absolument existentiel pour le pays le
moment que nous vivons est existentiel
pour le pays et entre nous vous me
parliez première question qui é
intéressante sur Trump je suis pas du
tout un fan de Trump et des Américains
mais imaginez qu'on a eu un Biden gâteux
mais on allait vers la 3è guerre
mondiale avec les Russes là on a de la
chance que Trump soit arrivver une
extrémiste qui nit pas pris la balle
dans la tête quand même après on peut
discuter de Trump et j'approuve pas
beaucoup de choses de Trump mais là donc
je reviens pour moi l'enjeu ce serait
aujourd'hui dans un monde idéal d'avoir
un président de la République qui dise
il y a une possibilité de paix la France
a une idée de la paix d'un compromis en
Ukraine d'une réconciliation il y a bien
une réconciliation entre la France et
l'Allemagne après trois conflits
mondiaux bon enfin de et
demi on peut quand même imaginer que les
ukrainiens et les Russes qui sont peuple
frère une guerre civile un jour se
réconciliie et surtout que on reprenne
des échanges vigilants avec la Russie
pour assoir notre puissance économique
au 21e siècle voilà ma ligne revenons
revenons sur guerre économique le
discours d'Emmanuel Macron ouis
concernant le enfin Emmanuel Macron va
pas parler d'Emmanuel Macron tout le
temps parce que il va passer
heureusement d'accord donc le le
discours du président de la République
concernant les intérêts vitaux européens
et français ou h est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il a pris
conscience du phénomène du rouleau
compresseur de la guerre
économique est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il a pris conscience que
la France et l'Europe vont se retrouver
au milieu du gay avec les États-Unis
d'un côté et le bloc anciennement
communiste et c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'il a décidé de se réarmer d'ardar en
faisant de la dette d'ardar pour se
réarmer
d'ardar alors vous allez trouver que je
suis peut-être partial et que peut-être
que je suis méfiant j'y crois pas je
crois plutôt que il a vraiment l'idée
s'il a une cohérence faut lui
reconnaître une cohérence et une idée
fix c'est que pour lui la France est
finie mais il a jamais dit ça non mais
attendez pour lui la France est fin
et il veut je pense léguer cette Europe
fédérale c'est un nouveau Jean monnaie
j'ai vu dans un livre de Jean de comment
il s'appelle Éric Branca la République
des fauxoyeurs à la fin il y a toute
l'affaire de la CED Communauté
européenne de défense et il y a une
citation de jean-met alors je sais pas
si elle est vrai mais enfin il la cite
qui avait confié à quelqu'un vous
vérifierez c'est à la fin du livre La
République des fauxoyeurs et et jean-
Monet dit pour moi la France n'est qu'un
résidu et toute ma politique est liée à
ça toute ma politique européenne est
liée à ça ce sont des gens qui peut-être
croient que la France est finie il n'y
croi pas il ne croi pas à la France et
donc tout le raisonnement c'est de dire
il faut fondre la France dans un
ensemble européen plus large voilà le
raisonnement et en fait Macron veut
avant de partir rendre irréversible ce
saau fédéral faut comprendre ça il a
surendetté le pays il l'a explosé à
travers un discours un autre discours de
fou qui est le discours du 12 juillet
2021 sur le covid vaccinez-vous tous et
vous allez sauver votre grand-mère il
savait d'ailleurs depuis 3 mois que
c'était faux que le vaccin n'empêchait
pas la transmission donc c'était un
discours mensonger c'est quand même
fascinant de voir que cet homme a fait
deux grands discours à la nation qui
étaient des discours de peur fondés sur
un mensonge et qui le savait vous allez
pas me faire faire croire qu'Emmanuel
Macron est assez bête pour pas savoir
que la Russie n'est en rien une menace
de la France et pas savoir que le vaccin
n'empêchait pas la transmission alors
que delfry l'avait dit au ministre de la
santé parlaz d'un homme qui avait une
ministre de la Santé qui affichait des
feuilles sanitaires dans l'aéroport de
Charles de Gaulle
à4 contre le covid oui sauf que on a
aujourd'hui la preuve c'est très
important que le vaccin fait diminuer la
charge virale de 50 % au bout d'une
semaine bon on a la preuve c'est faux on
a la preuve par Monsieur Delfi président
du conseil scientifique du Conseil de
défense même je sais plus euh qui a
avoué parce qu'il doit avoir
sérieusement mauvaise conscience euh ou
peur des tribunaux qui a avoué sur une
émission de France24 vous pouvez
vérifier qu'il a informé le ministre de
la Santé monsieur verérant en mars 2021
mars 2021 que le vaccin n'empêchait en
rien la transmission que donc on ne se
vaccinait que pour soi mais pas pour
empêcher de passer à sa grand-mère donc
ça faisait tomber tout le discours sur
le Pass sanitaire le passe vaccinal et
le discours de Macron 3 mois après
pourquoi je reviens là-dessus c'est pas
pour revenir sur cette période
dramatique d'ailleurs le discours c'est
ça précédait quand il nous incitait à
aller dans les théâtres non c'est le
discours où vous savez pris d'en dessous
à la Mussolini il nous avait euh c'est
gratuit ça encore c'est pas gratuit non
non les symboles quand quand vous faites
un discours le 12 juillet 2021 il il m'a
fait froid dans le dos ce discours comme
le deuxème et que vous instrumentalisez
la peur sur un peuple un peuple fatigué
vieillissant qui a besoin d'être
réveillé intelligemment par l'espérance
par la grandeur pas par la peur que vous
faites siamment peur aux gens pour leur
inoculer un vaccin non
testé à des milliards de doses alors que
vous savez pertinemment qui ne sert à
rien ça avait été testé un petit peu
quand même rien du tout phase 3 non
alors que vous savez qu'un vaccin
notamment sur les femmes enceintes il
faut 10 ans bon donc bref je trouve ça
tellement abominable ils savaient que
c'était un mensonge quel était votre
quelle est votre lecture du fait qu'ils
a poussé alors on reviendra sur les
questionsou par passe C vous inquitez
pas on a le temps c'est vous qui décidez
vous savez faire le coocalan bon comment
vous interprétez sa réaction vous
l'interprétez parce que la France avait
peut-être aider à construire un
laboratoire P3 et P4 en Chine il avait
peut-être d'autres informations que
c'était peut-être des recherches
militarisées il il a peut-être voulu
nous
protéger sur cette période moi je pars
de ce que je
connais et j'ai été reconnaissez-le le
plus Fran un des plus francs avec
Floriant Philippo euh sur cette affaire
euh parce que j'ai travaillé grâce au
confinement d'ailleurs se chose
confinement c'est ça non mais quand vous
êtes confiné chez vous et qu'il y a un
tel truc si vous êtes un citoyen normal
et encore plus un homme politique
j'aiétais député à l'époque je
m'interroge et quand j'ai compris qu'il
y avait un mensonge sur le la nature du
virus son origine puis sur sa gravité
quand j'ai compris qu'on mentait dans
les classifications à l'hôpital quand
j'ai compris qu'on dissimulait aux
Français et à tous les dans le monde
entier les traitements qui permettaient
de soignés sauver des vies quand j'ai
compris qu'on avait administré du
rivoteril à des personnes âgées pour les
tuer soi-disant pour abréger leurs
souffrance quand j'ai compris qu'on
mentait sur le vaccin qui transmettait
ou pas alors qu' enfin qui n'empêchait
pas la transmission non la
transmission quand j'ai quand j'ai
compris qu'on mentait sur la phase 3 et
que monsieur verérrant me mentait droit
dans les yeux à 6h du matin en séance de
l'Assemblée en me disant qu'on était
sorti de la phase 3 et qu'on était déjà
en phase 4 alors qu'on était en pleine
phase 3 et qui avait pas eu les tests
nécessaires et qui avait des effets
secondaires
possibles j'ai compris que tous ces
gens-là mentaient après pour quelle
raison il mentait j'en sais rien ce que
j'ai voulu pendant cette période et je
l'ai payé très cher en calomnie de tous
ordres j'ai voulu dire aux Français
méfiez-vous euh vous pouvez vous soigner
sans être vacciné vous n'avez pas besoin
de vous vacciner pour ne pas passer le
virus c'est pas vrai et si vous vaccinez
prenez à vos risques et péril pour les
effets secondaires je n'ai fait que dire
des faits face à ça j'ai été traîné dans
la boue par qui par tous ceux qui
avaient intérêt financièrement à coller
ses injections euh après pour quel motif
là pour le coup je ne je suis jamais
rentré là-dedans parce que je n'ai pas
d'élément de
preuve mais en tout cas moi j'ai alerté
les Français et tous les faits depuis
cette période m'ont donné raison comme
un certain nombre de personnes Christian
Peron Didier Raoul et les autres et on a
été traîné dans la boue et ça recommence
sur l'Ukraine et c'est ça qui me révolte
le plus si vous voulez dans la vie vous
pouvez être en désaccord avec des
gens moi j'ai pas la science infu je
suis pas monsieur vérité et Macron il
peut avoir raison sur des points ce que
je n'accepte pas c'est que à l'occasion
de ces crises que nous avons vécu qui
ont été alimenté par le pouvoir euh
exacerbé par le pouvoir notre pays a
perdu ce qui était peut-être
l'exception
française une rigueur d'analyse un goût
du débat hérité de siècle de débat et ce
qui me fait le plus de peine et ce qui
me m'oblige à agir voyez ce que je veux
dire à sortir de mon petit confort parce
que moi aussi je pourrais dire 27 ans
député 25 ans maire j'ai peut-être envie
de vivre aussi
euh mais je peux pas laisser mes
compatriotes comme ça je peux pas c'est
un devoir c'est un devoir d'alerte c'est
qu' un moment je peux pas accepter que
l'idée que je me fais de mon pays soit
une espèce de disparition pas seulement
du pays de la démocratie française de la
liberté de penser c'est même pas de
s'exprimer la liberté d'expression ça
fait longtemps qu'elle existe plus dans
notre pays bon mais la liberté de penser
voyez ce que je veux dire ils
s'attaquent ils ont restreint la liberté
d'expression et maintenant ils
s'attaquent à la liberté de
penser alors c'est vrai qu'en 2022 j'ai
fait une campagne présidentielle très
difficile parce que je savais entre Le
Pen Z mour et compagnie ça dur mais je
l'ai fait sur le thème la liberté
revenons revenons à mais voyez mais
parce que c'est ça qui est en jeu et
j'aimerais tellement que les Français
ouvrent les yeux il y en a des millions
qui ouvrent les yeux mais le propre des
dictatures c'est Vala qui avait dit très
bien ça je me souviens d'une interview
de Vala très intéressant il était il
était dans son chantier naval il y avait
eu un reportage sur la libération de la
Pologne et tout ça m'avait marqué
j'étais étudiant et à la télé j'ai vu
télévision j'ai vu valesa qui disait le
PROE d'une dictature c'est qu'on vous
fait croire que vous êtes seul
c'estàdire que on fait croire à chaque
citoyen qu'il est seul et qu'il peut pas
y arriver et le n'ayez pas peur de
Jean-Paul II avait eu un retentissement
absolument fabuleux en Pologne terre
chrétienne quand même mais parce que Val
a expliqué que le n'ayez pas peur a
permis à tous ces gens qui sont des
solitaires de voir qu'ils étaient des
millions de solitaires et en fait on vit
ça en ce moment en en tout cas moi je le
ressens comme ça je le ressens comme ça
des millions de solitaires en France
revenons sur ma question guerre
économique le discours d'Emmanuel Macron
alors oui pardon j'ai pas du tout
répondu à la question r le réarmement
est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils ont
compris que l'Europe allait terminé au
milieu du gay parce que quand on voit
les infrastructures pour acheminer le
gaz russe qui sont toutes soit foutu
soit en foutu le fait que les Russes
vont aussi peut-être se venger avec une
guerre économique sur le prix de
l'énergie et le fait qu'on achète quatre
fois plus cher le le gaz liqu c'est le
résultat de cette est-ce que on n'est
pas en train de se réarmer pour éviter
de se faire
dosser de quel réarmement vous parlez si
le réarmement le réarmement de Madame
vaner Leyen ça dépend de quoi on parle
voà perception des futurs conflits sur
la perception des futurs conflits que
l'Europe
pense sa défense autrement que sous la
protection des États-Unis ça ne peut
être qu'une bonne chose je suis pas
antiuropéen je suis antiunion européenne
donc queil y ait une pensée collective
du continent pour réfléchir aux menaces
parce que faut partir des menaces
ensuite il faut partir des moyens
ensuite il faut toujours respecter le
principe de la nation parce qu'on ne tue
pas on ne se fait pas tuer pour d'autres
pour ça que la c'est le dernier élément
de souveraineté nationale je prends
toujours l'exemple sur l'Europe de la
défense je fais une parenthèse mais je
vais revenir votre truc on me dit tout
le temps oui l'Europe de la défense et
puis c'est bien et tout je dis ah bon en
Irak quand Villepin et Chirak on dit
stop on aurait donc envoyé nos jeunes
combattre en Irak parce que Aznar et
Blair voulait qu'on aille en Irak c'est
ça l'Europe de la défense faut dire la
vérité aux Français l'Europe de la
défense c'est que on va combattre pour
des guerres qui ne sont pas les nôtres
on abandonne la le choix national
démocratique de décider si on envoie nos
enfants à la guerre c'est fondamental
donc je ne crois pas à l'Europe de la
défense en revanche que les pays les
nations d'Europe prennent conscience que
le parapluie américain c'est fini dans
les 50 ans qui viennent si on raisonne à
50 ans et que nous devons par nous-mêmes
par des coopérations d'État
améliorer notre défense oui deuxème
point et je viens à votre question si la
défense européenne d'aujourd'hui c'est
d'acheter des F35 américains l'Allemagne
vient de confirmer l'achat C F35 dont la
clé est chez Trump la clé d'utilisation
c'est pas de l'Europe de la
défense c'est un nouveau mécanisme
d'endettement pour acheter du matériel
américain et c'est complètement Pipo
alors là-dessus pour le coup je pense
que j'ose espérer que Macron est sincère
et qui préférait évidemment que les
Allemands achètent des rafales et qu'il
fait ça et je l'espère pour placer notre
industrie parce que nous sommes bons
dans ce domaine faut être honnête et que
donc nous avons de belles entreprises de
défense et que si on pouvait profiter de
ce qui se passe pour que ces entreprises
de défense et davantage de clients en
Europe puisque c'est en fait c'est le
seul endroit où on na pas de client bon
on vend nos Rafal en Égypte en Inde aux
Émirats mais pas en Europe bon ça oui
bien sûr mais
si on croit que pour arriver à ça il
faut abandonner la force de dissuasion
donner des milliards avant der de
l'abandonner hein il parle de
peut-être la sous-traiter aux Allemands
non non mais attendez on nous prend
vraiment pour des cons mais vraiment
c'est un plaisir d'être aussi bête pas
vous mais euh vous faites l'avocat du
diable
euh parce qu'en fait ce qui est très
intéressant au début il nous dit
parce que ça fait mieux le mot
stratégique c'est le mot valise bon il y
a un concept stratégique alors g
ambiguité stratégique voilà l'ambiguéa
même le général de Gaulle tout avait dit
in je connais l'histoire parur alors oui
il dit ça alors les gens disent bah oui
c'est quand même bien on est on est prêt
quand même à défendre les Allemands puis
le Français a un cœur d'or il veut
défendre la Terre entière bon il y a que
Salvini qui a été intelligent parce
qu'il est remarquable qui a dit quand
même euh je veux pas être défendu par un
fou bon donc voilà donc lui il est
lucide bon mais à part ça il faut bien
voir les Allemands et les Polonais les
Allemands ont dit tout de suite ah ben
nous on veut la force de dissuasion
française et l'inénara Monsieur Barot
qui nous sert de ministre d'affaires
étrangères qu'on a recruté dans un
centre de vacances
euh ou je sais pas où c'est pas fa ses
journé ah non non non non barreot Barot
a avoué dans une émission de radio un
matin j'écoute pas a avoué que il
négocia avec les Allemands pour une
contribution financière allemande à la
force de dissuasion français un peu
c'est bien ah bah oui mais celui qui
paye il décide il paye pas tout non non
non mais attendez à partir du moment où
vous mettez le doigt dans l'engrenage
d'un paiement allemand pour notre force
de dissuasion ça veut dire qu'il y a
plus de force de dissuasion française et
que vous avez donné aux Allemands des
centaines de milliards d'euros investis
par la France depuis
1960 pour rien
c'est un c'est alors là c'est plus de la
haute traison c'est le peloton
d'exécution dans la minute cléenceo il
est il aurait fusillé Macron déjà c'est
fini bon donc c'est pas possible et les
Polonais la ramènent en disant ben oui
attention nous on veut pas être sous le
parapluie français on veut la c-écision
donc ce qui se trame en ce moment et
c'est pour ça que je veux que nos
partenaires j'aimerais être moins seul
au sens j'aimerais que Le Pen bardela
Zemour tous s'expriment davantage
philiipo Philippo non Philippo et asinos
là-dessus sont clair et heureusement
qu'ils sont là
euh moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que la
classe politique dans son ensemble ça
mérite la censure immédiate je veux dire
quels sont les instruments qu'ils ont
moi j'aurais aimé que Marine Le Pen
dépose une motion de censure
immédiatement en disant voilà on a un
président de la République est en train
de
négocier l'abandon de notre force de
dissuasion ou le partage si vous
préférez de notre force de dissuasion
qui est un crime contre la nation je
censure le gouvernement immédiatement et
lesfi aurait voté et le gouvernement
était censuré et ça mettait Macron en
difficulté et puis elle aurait pu dire
et elle pourrait dire je désespère pas
de la convaincre
elle pourrait dire on on va signer la
destitution de Macron on entame la
destitutions on envoie un message for au
français non il se passe revenons à la
question sur le conflit ukrainien le
fait qu'on se réarme le fait que notre
président de la République verbalise une
angoisse oui non l'alimente il verbalise
peut-être une angoisse il l'alimente il
pe il met peut-être des mots sur son
angoisse il a peut-être compris queon
était en train d'être les dons de la
farce au milieu du bloc russe et du bloc
américain oui mais alors attendez
excusez-moi là je me j'essaie de
dialoguer
avec le diable l'avocat du diable
l'avocat du diable
s'il avait compris ça il aurait raison
un peu trop tard non non mais s'il avait
compris ça il saisirait la chance de la
paix en disant bravo Trump de faire la
paix avec Poutine la France est une
puissance de paix et d'équilibre nous
voulons un compromis en Ukraine c'est
une très bonne chose que l'Ukraine ne
rentre pas dans le temps c'est ce
qu'avait proposé mon prédécesseur JAC
Chirac c'est une je propose moi j'ai
fait un plan de paix vous le retrouvez
sur Internet 7 mars 2022 il y a une
clause de désarmement mutuel alors
attendez première chose l'Ukraine ne
rentre pas dans l'OTAN deuxième chose
euh démilitarisation totale de l'Ukraine
troisème chose euh réduction de
l'arsenal de missile des Russes et des
Américains en Europe
euh 4èe chose retrait des troupes russes
et des troupes européennes et américaine
qui n'existe pas sans doute en Ukraine
mais que tout le monde a vu euh vous a
pas vu enfin il y a des formateurs en
tout cas il y a 12 bases de la CIA qui
ont été répertoriés par le New York
Times donc c'est pas moi bon c pas des C
de vacances non c'était des bases de la
CIA pour rire aux frontières de
l'Ukraine vers la Russie tiens c'est
curieux bon et c'est un grand
journaliste américain qui l'a révélé du
New York Times donc il a des grands
journalistes dans dans le monde donc
bref faut arrêter de nous prendre pour
des enfants donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que on dessert les taux force
de l'ONU pour protéger les centrales
nucléaires
euh et puis compromis territorial sur le
donbas et la Crimée avec éventuellement
de nouveaux référendum bon euh pour
habiller la face sauver la face de tout
le monde et puis fin des sanctions
économiques et puis réarmement de
l'Europe parce qu'il faut être méfiant
s'agit pas de faire confiance à Poutine
surtout pour dire l'Ukraine est une zone
neutre ce qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû
cesser d'être nous nous nous replions
sur la Pologne les États baltes et la la
Roumanie ou là nous serons
intransigeentss donc attention vous
prenez pas pour des cons comolis et puis
à l'inverse nous vous offrons à vous à
russe des garanties de sécurité parce
que nous démilitarisons l'Ukraine ça
c'est un compromis je pense vers lequel
on va aller de fait et si la France
avait dit ça comme je l'avais proposé
dès le mois dès le le le mars 15 jours
après l'invasion de l'Ukraine nous
aurions été une puissance de paix
le sommet où il y a eu la peine négocié
à Istanbul en avril 2022 aurait eu lieu
à Paris notre image en Afrique aa été
autre chez les brick enfin voilà la
France auraitté la France il est pas
trop
tard une parole diplomatique qui V roup
sans quand même mais mais sous la 4e
République la parole diplomatique de la
France valit des roupis de sansonnet
regardez l'explodition de suess qui a
foiré lamentablement bon et puis 3 ans
après de Gaul est revenu et c'était
autre chose donc la France est pas
condamnée la France peut rebondir si
elle a sa tête des gens qui on l'esprit
structuré comment on peut rebondir alors
qu'on s'est fait bûter hors d'Afrique
comment on peut rebondir alors qu'on a
pas d'énergie bon marché comment on peut
rebondir alors qu'on a des matières
premières qui ont pris 40 % d'inflation
comment on peut rebondir alors qu'on a
pas les G femm qu'on n pas très bien
positionné en terme d'intelligence
économique et et intelligence
artificielle comment on peut rebondir
quand on a un système éducatif qui prend
qui boit la tasse un système hospitalier
qui boit la tasse on rebondit comment là
et et 3300 milliards de dettes parce
qu'on est la France
voilà parce que vous connaissez
l'histoire de France vous croyez que
Jean d'c avec son roi était bien barré
quand quand elle a libéré la France
Orléan non mais vous vous souvenez où on
en était si je peux me permettre bien
qu'on n pas vécu à cette époque à moin
qu'on soit réincarné euh vous croyez que
vous croyez qu'on était bien barré en 17
quand toute cette classe politique
lamentable tiens on ressemble beaucoup à
l'assemblée de 1917 là en ce moment euh
avant que Clémençon n'arrive ah c'est
gratuit ça aussi hein non c'est pas
gratuit non si vous voulez c'est pas
gratuit parce qu'on n pas une classe
politique à la hauteur des enjeux et
même des attentes des Français on peut
je veux dire on on va faire on va
revenir sur la politique mais vous
croyez qu'on était bien barré en
40 j'en parle pas et en 58 quand la
France avait 6 semaines de trésorerie 6
semaines de trésorerie donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que la France est un
grand pays quand même nous sommes la 6e
puissance 7e puissance mondiale on a des
trésors d'intelligence on a des grandes
entreprises on a des chercheurs on a des
intello on a des richesse au nom de quoi
simplement je vais vous dire ce qui
manque c'est une une volonté du courage
une méthode alors ça sera pas
facile et c'est pourquoi moi je relisis
si ça fait prétentieux
mais je me suis posé cette question et
puis il y a juste après les fêtes de
Noël je me suis dit c'est pas possible
il faut que je sois candidat à nouveau
il faut il faut que je sois candidat
parce qu'il faut que je puisse dire au
français ce que je propose et comment on
peut s'en sortir imolation devant
l'Assemblée nationale c'était aussi plus
efficace c'était une solution mais ça
aurait fait trop plaisir à mes ennemis
donc donc je veux pas leur faire cette
joie et donc j'ai commencé à écrire mon
discours que vous pouvez retrouver sur
internet du 8 mars qui est mon discours
de candidature mais c'est pas pour être
candidat c'est parce que j'ai essayé de
réfléchir et je me suis dit en fait ma
seule différence par rapport aux autres
c'est pas ce que je vais proposer sur la
sécurité sur l'école sur l'immigration
sur la compétitivité sur l'hôpital le
tout le monde est à peu près d'accord
sur ce qu'il faut faire il y a eu 150
rapports sur tous les sujets la seule
différence c'est que pour faire tout ça
il faut redonner le pouvoir au peuple
c'estàdire retrouver une démocratie
parce qu'on fera pas ça sans les
Français et sans les associés de gaaule
s'est sorti du gupier algérien par le
référendum sinon il pouvait pas s'en
sortir et le deuxième point c'est de
retrouver notre indépendance nationale
c'est-à-dire de retrouver les manettes
les leviers du pouvoir com on fait avec
3300 milliards de dettes mais milliards
de dettes tous les pays ont des milliers
de milliards de dettes la question
attaqu leur dette sur les marchés aussi
oui mais attendez si la France j'ai
écrit un bouquin là-dessus valpognon
fait les économies nécessaire et relance
sa production fait du protectionnisme
intelligent relancer la production avec
quelle énergie ahah vous connaissez pas
ma réforme ma réforme c'est en plus là
on peut le faire même l'Espagne et le
Portugal l'ont fait on peut dire euh
c'est-à-dire que même dans l'Union
européenne et je veux qu'on en finisse
avec cette structure je veux en sortir
de l'Union européenne je vais alors je
ça je veux 2 minutes là-dessus mais je
finis sur l'énergie sur
l'énergie on ne doit
plus faire partie de l'organisation
européenne de marché ce qu' le Portugal
et l'Espagne l'ont
décider on doit revenir à un monopole de
production
Ed
pour l'électricité et on doit fixer un
prix de revient un prix de vente de
l'électricité en fonction de notre prix
de revient plus les amortissements
nécessaires pour réinvestir dans nos
nouvelles centrales allez entre 50 et 70
€ le
mgaw le gouvernement a fixé 70
aujourd'hui le prix libre est à 53 c'est
monté à 200 il faut sortir de ce système
indexé sur le gaz allemand ça veut dire
gaz russe oui enfin le gaz le prix du
gaz en Allemagne qui découle de tout qui
est maintenant le prix américain donc à
cause de la du nos brillants stratège
euh donc très clairement la France a la
possibilité à la différence de
l'Allemagne de l'Italie et des autres
d'avoir une électricité à 50
€. 55 €
largement il faut le faire du jour au
lendemain vous donnez déjà une bouffée
d'oxygène à notutre Industrie vous
retrouvez l'avantage comparatif qui a
tué l'Allemagne avec la complicité de
nos dirigeants français et de nos médias
et de nos eng et de ces abrutis qui
foutent des éolienne partout qui servent
à rien vous savez combien coûte alors
faudit vérifier parce que j'ai plus le
chiffre en mémoire mais les éoliennes
marines qu'on nous met partout là et qui
sont achetés à prix d'or et là il faudra
un jour une enquête sans doute du
parquet financier pour savoir pourquoi
on a choisi certains opérateurs et à
quel prix on rachète l'électricité
j'en dis pas plus mais ceux qui
m'entendront sauront de quoi je parle
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on peut là on a un
atoutoriser cet atout on le valorise
tout de suite ensuite on peut prendre
des mesures pour le produire en France
j'en ai détaillé des dizaines produire
en France on peut mettre en place une
politique même dans l'Union européenne
et puis bien évidemment il faut en finir
avec l'Union européenne si on veut
retrouver notre liberté c'est tout le
sens de ma candidature je serai le seul
candidat qui veut en finir avec l'Union
européenne c'est-à-dire retrouver
l'indépendance nationale l'armée à nos
frontières notre prix de
l'électricité le droit français
supérieur au droit européen par
référendum c'est très important ça c'est
fondamental hein donc on retrouve le
franc non là je suis pas encore au franc
euh le droit français le budget français
et puis bien évidemment ne plus obéir à
l'Union européenne rien on arrive au
Conseil européen un nouveau président il
dit voilà moi c'est fini et dernier
point bien évidemment on paye plus nous
sommes le pays avec l'Allemagne et les
Pays-Bas qui paye qui pay pay les TR
seul on paye plus vous savez dans les
jeux d'enfants vous connaissez ces trucs
qu'on met dans nos villes pour les fêtes
d'enfants qui sont avec de l'air vous
savez des jeux d'enfants énormes là où
les enfants monte savez sont avec des
souffleries vous coupez la soufflerie
ça tombe on arrive et là on se fait
déposser par les Chinois non non non
rien du tout arrêtez avec vos
chinois là on arrive et on dit écoutez
la France ne joue plus la France ne paye
plus la France n'obéit plus la France ne
participe plus ce qu'a fait le général
de Gaulle d'une autre manière avec la
politique de la chaise vide en 66 ce
qu'a fait margarette tcher dans un sens
quand elle a dit i want my money back
ils sont tous écrasés hein le jour où la
France fait ça ça il y a plus d'Union
Européenne et c'est ce que j'essaie
désespérément d'expliquer à mes amis
Philippo et
assino pourquoi vous faites pas un
groupe ah bah ça j'en rêve mais on va en
parler parce que ils confondent
l'objectif et le
moyen l'objectif c'est l'indépendance
nationale retrouver notre liberté de
manœuvre mais ça ne veut pas dire ne pas
travailler avec nos voisins ça veut dire
retrouver notre liberté frontières
budget lois et à terme monnaie pour
pouvoir mener une politique de
redressement nationale c'est le sens de
ma candidature eux disent frxit frxite
frxite et ils m'accusent pour être clair
que je serai pas très à souverainiste
très net parce que je veux pas le frxit
tout de suite je leur dis oui frxit
peut-être mais l'ennui du frxit SEC si
je puis dire à la Britannique c'est que
l'Union européenne demeure
demeure à côté de nous moi je préfère
parce que je pense que la France est un
grand
pays avant d'utiliser l'escalier de
secours c'estàdire le frexit qu'il
propose je veux essayer autre chose
qu'est-ce qu'une sorte de frexit
collectif c'est-à-dire je veux dynamiter
cette instance je veux qu'on la
France propose à ses partenaires de
partir avec elle vous comprenez ce que
je veux dire c'est-à-dire que les Orban
les mélonies qui peuvent pas le faire
parce qu'ils dépendent de l'argent euh
euh même les Allemands se disent mais
finalement est-ce que la France comme en
1789 en 1848 la France éternelle
n'aurait pas raison cette structure elle
est morte elle nous emmerde elle est
elle est en train de détruire l'Europe
est-ce que finalement on devrait pas
reconstruire quelque chose une Europe
des nations l'Europe des nations
Gaulistes des nations libre souveraine
qui travaillent ensemble sur des projets
à la carte comme Airbus qui n'a pas été
fait dans l'Union européenne je vous
rappelle et pourquoi je ne suis pas pour
le frxit immédiat ou du moins je n'en ai
pas fait le l'étendard de mon projet
politique c'est une carte qu'il faut
garder donc Filippo et astino ont raison
de garder cette carte mais en faire le
seul moyen je trouve ça maladroit pour
deux raisons je trouve ça maladroit
vis-à-vis des Français parce que ça fait
peur aux Français qui légitimement se
disent mais pourquoi partir est-ce qu'on
peut pas quand même retravailler avec
les autres et puis surtout je suis
convaincu cette structure de l'Union
européenne va crever comme l'Union
soviétique à l'époque qu'elle est
extrêmement fragile en fait alors
l'Union soviétique s'est effondré avec
la politique de d'armement de guerre
froide est-ce que vous pensez qu'on en
est
là répétez votre question l'Union
soviétique s'est effondrée à cause de de
la surenchè de rigane c'est ça que
voulez dire est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
en est là sans les matières premières
sans les colonies sans le Texas sans la
Sibérie
moi je pense que la France avec ce
qu'elle a si elle a une volonté si elle
a une méthode si elle a un peu de temps
si elle est méthodique n'oubliez pas que
Poutine a prévu la sortie de Swift et
compagnie il l'a pas fait d'un coup euh
euh si que de Gaulle a fait partir le
temps quand il avait la bombe nucléaire
euh voilà et c'est pourquoi je moi ce
que j'ai envie de proposer aux Français
ce que je vais leur proposer c'est une
reprise de enfin une une reconquête de
notre indépendance
réfléchie progressive euh raisonnable
capable de les rassembler et de les
convaincre c'est ça que je veux faire
quand je veux répondre à la question sur
mes amis Filippo et asino c'est que je
suis très partagé parce
que j'adore les vidéos
d'asino j'admire le courage de Philippo
très sincèrement euh ce sont des êtres
brillants qui sont dans le vrai
mais qui ont
tendance comment dire à s'enfermer sur
leur propre j'allais dire boutique
politique
et je trouve
dommage et je comprendre nos électeurs
je trouve dommage que les souverainistes
français ne soient pas
capable de bousculer des nuances entre
nous des
nuances moi je veux un frxite collectif
pour pour dynamiter l'Union européenne
eux ils veulent un frxite simple enfin
je veux dire c'est des nuances par
rapport à l'essentiel et bien je trouve
absolument absurde j'allais dire
criminel politiquement que c'est
chamaillerie souverainistes voilà et je
veux bousculer ça aussi parce que
j'estime que puisqu'ils sont pas
capables de s'entendre entre eux euh et
ben il faut que la base S se rassemble
et je suis convaincu qu'en France il y a
au moins 20 % 20 %
de souverainiste d'indépendantiste
d'amoureux de la France et c'estes 20 %
je veux leur parler et je veux qu'il se
rassemble c'est ça mon obj qu'est-ce que
vous allez qu'est-ce que vous allez dire
au 80 % ah bah déjà attendez Jacques
shirac a été élu avec 19 % au premier
tour
donc moi j'ai mon plus grand score ça a
été 5 %
2017 j'estime que il y a 20 % de
Français au moinsah il y en a c'est très
simple il y a eu un sondage dans le ou
c'est pas moi qui l'ai fait pour une
fois il y a eu un sondage qui m'était
favorable qui disait qu'il y avait 19 %
des Français qui souhaitaient ma
candidature j'ai eu ça je me suis dit ou
là miracle donc je pense qu'il a 20 %
puis tous les sondages de popularité je
suis entre 17 et 25 donc il y a 20 % de
Français mais c'est colossal qui veulent
déjà reprendre l'indépendance de la
France qui sont
gauliens qui ont l'esprit clair enfin du
moins qui sont de notre avis les autres
on peuvent avoir l'esprit clair et pas
de mon avis hein j'ai pas cette
prétention mais disons qu' ont une
vision ces 20 % là plutôt que de se
chamailler entre les patriotes l'uppr
debout la France ceci cela vous croyez
pas qu'il faut leur parler et leur
donner un programme indépendance
nationale retour de la démocratie retour
de la démocratie c'est fondamental hein
c'est le RIC non non mais attendez c'est
le RIC c'est le référendum c'est le vote
blanc revenons à la géopolitique et à la
guerre économique oui la France
des matières premières la souveraineté
des matières premières comment on fait
pour aller chercher notre uranium
comment on fait pour aller chercher
notre coton pour les Bours d'obus notre
poudre comment on fait s'il y a pas un
marché européen pour faire descendre les
tarifs c'est pas le marché européen qui
va le marché il est mondial arrêtez avec
votre histoire de marché européen vous
êtes pas quand même comme ceux qui
croient que le monde s'arrête à
l'Europe en fait l'Union
européenne a été moins vite si on
réfléchit vous me faites réfléchir à
quelque chose pour essayer de vous
répondre de manière
différente l'Union européenne a été
moins vite que la mondialisation en fait
l'Union européenne c'est un truc daté
des années 50 et le monde a été plus
vite que l'Union européenne et l'Union
européenne est empétrée dans ce
système oligarchique non démocratique or
dans la mondialisation j'en suis
convaincu ce sont les nation bien dans
leur pot c'est-à-dire démocratique ou
pas ou avec une identité vous avez des
pays qui ont pas de démocratie mais qui
ont une
identité qui sont pas
obligatoirement grandes grosses mais qui
sont agile et qui ont une ligne si vous
regardez et donc je pense que la France
avec son
identité une
volonté sa puissance est tout à fait
capable dans le grand bain de la
mondialisation d'exister donc les
matières premières je reviens à votre
question précise il y a celle qu'on peut
rapatrier en France c'estàdire
relocaliser par exemple les obus la
poudre j'ai vu que la poudre alors vous
vérifierez je pas dire une connerie
parce que j'essaie d'être le plus
honnête possible avec vous vous savez le
tarif ici si vous dites une connerie non
mais j'ai lu alors après ce qu'on lit
dans la presse se méfier enfin j'ai lu
qu'on apportait de la poudre d'Australie
alors faudra vérifier mais on doit ord
relocaliser beaucoup de choses premier
point ensuite si on a une politique non
alignée une politique qui parle au monde
qui ne dépend pas d'un
camp notre position en Afrique sera pas
du tout la même si on a une politique
africaine je suis le seul en 2017 et en
2022 avoir eu un plan pour l'Afrique on
m'a
rionné intéresser aucun journaliste
parisien mais le premier défi un des
premiers défis c'est le défi
démographique africain et le défi du
développement
comment on rond avec la franceafrique
comment on on on on on a un partenariat
gagnant gagnant comment on valorise les
matières premières par exemple en RDC au
lieu de les importer de les piller via
les Émirats et le Rwanda en sont des
choses sérieuses là vous pouvez avoir
une politique on a le BRGM qui est un
des plus
emblématiques on peut faire des choses
non vous dites oui je vous vois faire là
non non non mais au nom de quoi on
pourrait pas
faire il y a pas besoin c'est pas parce
que vous coopérez avec vos voisins vous
êtes plus efficace après s'il peut y
avoir des coopérations par exemple dans
mon esprit d'Europe à la carte la France
a son indépendance ça maîtrise de sa
souveraineté rien ninterdit avec trois
pays de bâtir Airbus des matières
premières si vous voulez pour avoir du
lithium du cobalt du cuivre et tout ce
que vous voulez ça ça me gêne pas je ne
vous dis pas qu'il faut être toujours
tout seul surtout je vous dis qu'il faut
penser notre avenir
démocratie indépendance puissance quelle
lecture vous avez quelle lecture vous
avez de Donald Trump et du
grland j'aime pas trop Leland ou Donald
Trump non j'aime pas trop la c'est c'est
le problème des
gens je pèse mes mots comment vous dire
c'est tout le problème des gens qui ont
du génie et de la folie c'est le moment
où il doivent
s'arrêter voilà c'est que je nai
comprends toujours pas l'intérêt des
déclarations de Donald Trump sur le
Canada le Grenland et même le Golf du
Mexique si je vous dis guerre de
ressources bien sûr j'ai compris qu'il y
a une guerre de ressources mais est-ce
que vous croyez que la meilleure méthode
d'abord les Américains sont déjà au
Grenland en matière d'intérêt économique
d'après ce que je sais et vous
vérifierez euh et donc ces provocations
verbales ne servent pas pour moi les
États-Unis et et c'est tout le drame de
Donald Trump c'est qu'il a des des
éclairs de génie je pense sur
l'Ukraine parce qu'il est en train de
faire l'entente avec la Russie sur les
matières premières pour ne pouvoir
isoler la Chine parce qu'on nont pas
compris les anes qui n bah oui mais les
anes qui nous gouverne n toujours pas
compris et euh il a des éclairs de génie
je pense et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il a tous les lobes économiques en ce
moment contre lui aux États-Unis sur
l'idée des relocalisations parce qu'il a
compris que les États-Unis peuvent pas
éternellement dépendre de de la Chine et
du reste pour produire et ça va de ça
bloque toutes les chaînes de valeur
économique tout ce qui a été créé de
mondialisation et vous voyez bien les en
ce moment montter les protestations
économiques des gros intérêts
économiques donc là je trouve que
d'ailleurs entre nous Trump fait plus
pour les écolos tous les écolos de la
cable en France mais en lutant contre la
mondialisation sauvage il fait plus pour
l'écologie et les gaz à effet de serre
des cargot que tous les écoloes qui sont
en bicyclette à Paris hein bon enfin
c'est une parenthèse donc ce que je veux
dire c'est que là je trouve qu'il y a
des choses intéressantes chez Trump pour
son pays pas pour le nôtre mais pour son
pays et j'aimerais que moi les Français
et les Européens bah comprennent que il
y a pas d'avenir sans une industrie
forte sans une énergie bon marché qui a
pas d'avenir sans une puissance
économique voilà pourquoi on l'a pas
compris du moins pourquoi le
gouvernement l'ont pas compris l'ont pas
anticipé c'était parce que c'était de la
subordnation de vote en disant voilà
votez pour pour moi je vais faire des
petits parters de fleurs voter pour moi
je vais être plus ouvert mais
derrière je sais pas comment je vais
désinguer fa alors il y a plusieurs
choses c'est le grand mystère des 30
dernières années je suis en train
d'écrire un bouquin j'espère pouvoir
finir pour je dois le rendre fin mai
c'est
dur j'essaie d'analyser parce que j'ai
vécu ça j'ai été élu à l'Assemblée en 97
j'ose pas le dire mais ça fait 30 ans
presque ça 30 ans en 2027 donc j'ai vécu
tout ça j'ai vu tous ces hommes et ces
femmes et ces femmes oui enfin
pardonnez-moi bon tous ces êtres humains
les droits humains enfin tout le bazar
euh donc j'ai vu tout ça c'était pas des
gens malhonnête trop dans
l'ensemble non mais par rapport à la aux
classes politiqu des autres pays ça se
voyait peut-être un peu moins non je
honnêtement je ferai pas de la démagogie
là-dessus parce que je pense qu'on a une
classe politique qui est plus bête comm
honnête
euh mais j'ai peut-être tort parce que
je suis naïf euh et trop pur vous avez
pas de compte en Suisse ah non ça bah il
y a longtemps que je serai en prison vu
mes positions ça c'est au moins vous
avez l'assurance que vous a fait sauter
vos comptes bancaires non on m'a pas
fait sauter mes comptes bancaires mais
mais j'ai eu tous les contrôles
possibles et imaginables quand j'étais
maire de hier et la seule chose qu'ils
ont pu trouver c'est les barques surliè
où j'avais pas mis en concurrence parce
que je trouvais pas de de de location de
bar j'ai des barques sur l' à la
propriété kbot et là j'avais pas mis en
concurrence parce qu'il y avait trois
barques le dimanche d'un type qui
mettait tris barques sur l'eau pour
faire payer j'ai pas plus c'est le seul
truc qu'ils ont trouvé voyez donc donc
non mais bon passons ça là-dessus j'ai
pas d'inquiétude heureusement je peux me
regarder dans ma glace bon l'ennui c'est
que mon parti est pauvre mais ça c'est
l'ennui mais au moins je peux me
regarder dans ma glace et il me tiennent
pas parce que je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui se tiennent dans la
vie politique
française bref je reviens à mon idée
tiennent comment bah ils se tiennent je
te tiens par tu me tiens par la
barbichette ils doivent avoir des choses
qui se tiennent mais dans l'ensemble ils
sont plus bêtes que malhonnêtes
franchement la vraie question que je me
pose on les politiques qu'on mérite
attendez vous vous allez trop vite pour
moi moi je suis un
LAN je vais répondre mais d'abord la
vraie question que vous m'avez poser qui
est fondamentale c'est comment se
fait-il qu'un pays qui avait tant
d'atout ils ai pu dilapider un peu comme
un fils de famille
qui hériterait d'une fortune et qui en
une génération jouerait tout au jeu vous
pensez à qui je pense à personne j'en
sais rien mais voyez c'est un peu ça ce
qui s'est passé
et pourquoi je crois qu'il y a un
mélange de trois
choses il y a des intérêts c'està-dire
qu'il y en a qui sont soumis à des
intérêts notamment américains ou des
intérêts d'entreprise tout simplement
courttermiste vous avez des preuves de
ça bah j'ai des preuves quand je dis des
intérêts ça veut pas dire de la
corruption de l'argent par exemple
est-ce que vous trouvez normal que les
hauts fonctionnaires de Bercy et
pantouflés dans des grandes entreprises
américaines ils ont pas tous pantouflé
non mais beaucoup quand le responsable
des participations de l'État je sais
plus son nom pantoufle la banque of
America ou un autre je sais plus c'est
pas normal je suis désolé quand
la haute administration de l'État qui
avait le sens du service public à
reconstruit la France sous de gaaule se
vend des entreprises étrangères c'est
qu'il y a quelque chose qui cloche
excusez-moi je préférais d'ailleurs
qu'on les paye mieux et qu'ils aillent
pas pantoufler donc c'est pas acceptable
ça veut dire qu'il y a une délicessence
donc premier point il y a les intérêts
c'est des intérêts c'est pas de la
corruption c'est des intérêts une masse
quand vous avez plein de gens qui ont
des intérêts court terme financiers bah
ils ont plus l'intérêt de la nation le
bien commun le bien commun deuxième
point il y a la mode le drame de la mode
la mode écolo la mode européenne les
de000es de substitution d'une gauche
orpheline B oui oui c'est c'est chiant
de s'occuper du peuple pour la gauche et
pour la droite aussi d'ailleurs c'est
c'est c'est quand même dingue de se dire
que ces gens ont oublié le social et
qu'ils ont pour eux c'est plus plus
important de faire la trottinette à
Paris que de s'occuper des pauvres c'est
pas comm ça à la gauche pas que les
trottinettes à Paris non mais au moment
du tournant de la rigueur de miteran
après la miteran est élu
sur légitimement une soif de justice
sociale le myth de la la gauche et et
moi je suis très moi je suis très social
au sens gaulist social donc j'aurais pu
être chev mentiste entre nous hein bon
donc moi je trouve ça bien parce que moi
j'ai toujours été révolté par les
inégalités d'argent de ça m'a toujours
atteint et j'ai je suis pas un homme
enfin je je n'aime pas l'inégalité
combien vous gagnez bah je gagnais je
gagnais quand j'étais député 5000 € plus
et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je vais avoir ma
retraite de l'Assemblée voilà combien je
sais pas encore dans les 3 4000 4000
5000 je suis très gâté 3 4000 5000 quand
je l'aurai je vous dirai hein mais dans
ces eau-l hein et je suis déjà très gâté
hein
euh mais au-delà de ça j'en étais où
vous m'avez interrompu la gauche sociale
oui la gauche sociale les trottinettes à
Paris oui mais c'est très important je
vais vous dire pourquoi
mitteran soif
sociale attente du peuple tournant de la
rigueur mitéran a choisi l'Europe au
détriment du social voilà clair la
gauche effondrée fait il fallait un myth
de substitution le myth de substitution
c'est l'Europe c'était mitteran et tous
les autres les de l'or les Hollandes les
toute cette
génération et puis ensuite comme
l'Europe c'était
l'Europe l'Europe contre le peuple
puisque on a voté on a gagné le nom et
ben après ils ont inventé l'écologie et
l'écologie c'est formidable parce que
c'est l'écologie pour les plus riches
c'est l'écologie des bobos c'est
l'écologie des gens aisés c'est
l'écologie des sachants et et puis ça
permet d'avoir bonne conscience et moi
ça me révolte que on privilégie qu'on
des
milliards pour une fausse écologie et
que le social soit complètement
abandonné on préfère mettre des
milliards dans la fausse écologie mais
pas dans les hôpitaux comment ça va se
terminer pas dans
l'école pas avoir un pays qui s'en sort
s'il y a pas de justice comment ça va se
terminer cette histoire on a 3300
milliards de dettes on est bouté d'un
peu partout les Russes sont fâchés les
Américains sont fâchés les chinois sont
en
embuscade la France à 3 ans on fait quoi
à 3 dans les trois prochaines qu'est-ce
qui va se passer qu'est-ce qui va se
passer on peut se faire attaquer notre
dette on pe re en conflit avec la Russie
ouvert quand on voit les Allemands dire
que bah ils veulent une bombe nucléaire
aussi parce qu'ils ont très très peur de
de la guerre qui se profile alors ils
ont selon il d'ici 2029 en fait ils
veulent alimenter la guerre ils veulent
saboter la paix c'est peut-être pas ce
qui Ann attendez moi je vous dis non
mais non mais c'est quand Mme
ext ces gens sont quand même
extraordinaires pourquoi il v
r C'est mon interrogation c'est quand
même on est dans un monde de fou là on
vit une période complètement folle au
moment où il y a la paix
possible ceux qui pourrai en profiter le
plus et qui ont le plus souffert de la
guerre qui a affaibli le continent
européen
font tout pour saboter la paix et créer
un conflit avec la Russie expliquez-moi
pourquoi Olaf Gunter ont peut-être
compris que bah sans gaz pas cher sans
matières premières ils allaient vite se
retrouver en apesanteur oui mais ben
justement ils vont se
faire justement justement si les
Allemands avaient un peu de jujotte ils
dirait oui non mais moi je suis pas
comme vous je si les Allemands avaient
un peu du jot dirait on a la chance
inouie de pouvoir faire un virage sur
l'aile euh en profitant de l'arrivée de
Trump pour se réconcilier avec les
Russes lever les sanctions rebattir un
partenariat tout en étant vigilant sur
notre défense pour la Pologne les pays
baltes et la ligne il s'agit pas d'être
faible il s'agit
simplement de voir les de hiérarchiser
les défis le premier défi il est de
produire et de retrouver une puissance
économique le deuxième défi il est de
bloquer nos frontières et de développer
l'Afrique pour éviter un remplacement de
population qui rend malheureux à la fois
les immigrés qui arrivent et les
Français qui sont là et le troisième
défi il est de d'avoir une justice
sociale minimum pour éviter
l'appauvrissement des plus pauvres et et
les inégalités à vomir le premier défi
c'est foutu là pourquoi c'est fout dans
les trois prochaines années mais
qu'est-ce que vous en savez d'abord il
va y avoir des é en France on se bat
pour
ça mais attendez si c'était foutu je
seraai pas devant
vous je me fais l'avocat du diable non
mais vous faites votre boulot moi
j'estime que c'est jamais foutu moi ce
qui me sauve vous savez il y a qu'un
truc qui me sauve Stéphan s journé non
ah B mince alors je sais pas qui
c'est vu les Bros F du ski non mais non
mais ce qui me sauve je vais vous dire
ce qui me sauve
c'est le peu de lecture historique que
j'ai eu dans ma vie c'est j'étais quand
j'avais 14 ans 13 ans j'étais passionné
des livres d'histoire je lisais tous les
Castello c'est les mode de mes parents
les alin deco les machins j'ai dévoré
l'histoire de France et l'histoire du
monde je et quand vous lisez l'histoire
et quand vous avez un minimum de culture
historique son je suis pas un historien
ou là j'ai pas cette prétention mais
vous savez que les situations se
redressent très vite ouis mais est-ce
que là le système est-ce que le système
est tellement intriqué in que la période
de sang et de larmes et de sueur va
tellement être importante intensité
d'une intensité tellement
question que ça risque de déstabiliser
le pays on a des minorités qui sont un
peu fâchées contre d'autres minorités un
peu fâché on a une gauche qui est fâchée
avec droite qui est fâché très juste
c'est-à-dire que malheureusement
l'histoire de France prouve et le
tempérament français aussi ajouter à
cela des médias qui engelivent tout pour
endormir les
Français ou pour éviter de les les les
abattre non pour éviter qu'ils
réagissent et qu'il réagissent contre
ceux qui nous endorment et qui profitent
du système qui nous endorment nos
dirigeants nos dirigeants politique
économique qui profite d'un système bon
donc en fait vous savez chacun vit sur
la bête donc pourvu que ça dur comme
disait la mère de Napoléon bon
donc je pense que vous vous avez raison
malheureusement l'histoire de France a
prouvé que le pays n'arrivait pas à se
réformer avant la catastrophe et on voit
bien que là comme dans une tragédie
grecque tous les éléments de la pièce de
la tragédie se met en place et donc
c'est évident que dans les mois qui
viennent nous pouvons avoir un une crise
de la dette crise de la dette que je
pense Emmanuel Macron en bon banquier
a facilité inconsciemment ou
consciemment parce que c'est le meilleur
moyen de liquider le pays de lui
expliquer que il est ruiné d'ailleurs
ils vont saisir l'épargne vous verrez ce
que je vous dis euh ils vont saisir
l'épargne des Français l'inén arable à
la minque qui sera aussi convoqué devant
les tribunaux de l'histoire comme
traître à la nation euh il a donné des
mauvais conseil non non attendez c'est
trop facile he président de la société
d'autoroute qu' seolier les Français ça
va bon donc point de vue oui c'est mon
point de vue bah j'assume al la main qui
a déjà mais au moins il a le franchise
il a dit faut un emprunt forcé sur les
Français tous ceux qui payent sur
l'impôt sur le revenu
paieront la première année la moitié de
l'impôt qu'ils ont payé et puis on leur
rendra ça sera l'emprunt russe quoi au
mauvais sens du terme pour ceux qui ont
de la mémoire donc ça ça nous pend au
nez c'est prêt tout est prêt vous avez
de l'épargne moi non j'ai enfin de
l'épargne immobilière mais pas j'ai
jamais été doué pour combien sur votre
compte en bque mais ça vous regarde pas
qu'est-ce que vous avez pris comme
mécanisme pour protéger votre épargne ah
ben j'ai jamais eu d'action je suis pas
doué pour ça moi je crois en la pierre
c'est mon côté paysan c'est le proverbe
non quand le sang commence à couler dans
les rues il est temps d'investir dans la
pierre ah bon bah alors mais c'est pas
le problème moi le problème c'est pas ça
le problème ce sont les Français
excusez-moi le problème ce sont les
Français moi ça me fait de la peine que
des Français économiser toute leur vie
et travailler dur et qu'on a un
gouvernement qui est surendetté le pays
avec la folie du covid avec leur laxisme
général c'était que 250 milliards oui
bah c'est pas Malfin un peu plus que 250
un peu plus au moins 300 si c'est pas
plus qu' a endetté sur surendetté le
pays et que maintenant on va nous dire
enfin quand même parce que je pense
qu'en fait l'affaire de la menace russe
elle est surtout financière ils vont
nous dire dire mais enfin vous êtes pas
un bon français enfin avec les méchants
russes qui arrivent là vous voulez pas
donner la moitié de l'impôt sur le
revenu que vous avez payé vous voulez
pas donner 2 % de votre assurance vie
enfin quand même c'est lamentable et
puis vous aurez tous les idiots utiles
de la gauche tous les journal de France
Info qui diront les riches ne veulent
pas donner pour les forts de la nation
et tout le monde sera riche tous les
gens qui ont un compte éparne seront
riches voilà ça ça nous pasend au neé
dans les 6 mois qui viennent et je pense
que la dramatisation de sur la Russie et
aussi lié à son sa grande inquiétude sur
la situation de la dette française vous
arrêtez une seconde oui et l'incapacité
je finis du gouvernement baayrou à tenir
le budget le budget de la France n'est
plus tenu aujourd'hui je je vous donc ça
c'est premier danger on va défendre
Emmanuel Macron une seconde ah ben ça
n'arrête pas ici pourquoi je pensais pas
que c'était le dernier li défenditu
touours êt équilibré mais je sais donc
Emmanuel Macron voit l'industrie
l'économie de guerre russe où il
produisent en un mot
pratiquement autant que toute l'Europe
en terme d'obus d'armement mais
qu'est-ce qu'il produisent d'autres
arrêtez 40 % du budget va vers la la
défense et donc il se dit on va vers une
paix qui ne sera pas une paix ils vont
continuer de s'armer et ensuite derrière
ils vont nous mettre une branlée mais
non mais ça c'est du délire attendez
attendez attendez il faut je sais pas
pourquoi vous êtes dans cette espèce
deavocat du diable non mais parce que
Macon voit ça il y a aucun traité de Pai
désarm non mais attendez on laisse
l'Europe sur le front de l'Est r quel
contresens la Russie est un pays musque
entend oui mais elle est fausse archif
fausse la Russie est un pays affaibli la
Russie est un pays en déclin
démographique la Russie est un pays qui
se surarme par rapport et qui et qui
n'investit pas dans d'autres domaines
parce que son obsession est de
reconstituer une défense un homland
autour de ses intérêts voilà ce n n'est
pas la menace la vraie menace on ferait
mieux de s'interroger sur ce que fait la
Chine on ferait mieux de s'interroger
sur la puissance chinoise dans les
nouvelles
technologies enfin quel
contresens mais vous savez on vit
toujours ça c'est aussi une grande leçon
de l'histoire en 40 ils ont fait la
ligne
magino
aujourd'hui en fait il surf sur des
vieux schémas du PACT de Varsovie de
l'Union soviétique il y a il y a 60 ans
ça n'a aucun sens les vrais défis où
sont-ils la bombe africaine la bombe
africaine la bombe islamiste la
puissance économique de la Chine la
puissance des nouvelles technologies aux
États-Unis le réchauffement
climatique non pourquoi vous faites
laamou parce que j'en ai marre de
ça parce que même s'il y a réchauffement
climatique il y a réchauffement
climatique même s'il y a réchauffement
climatique je n'ai pas moi la capacité
de l'analyser je vous dis très
franchement sur cette question je suis
dubitatif admettons qu'il a
réchauffement
climatique
admettons est-ce qu'il est lié à la
fameuse effet de serre du carbone ou
est-ce qu'il est lié tout simplement au
cycle de la Terre du Soleil et cetera je
n'en sais rien
admettons par principe de précaution
qu'il soit lié à l'activité humaine
admettons mais moi je dis à à tous nos
partenaires si j'étais élu en 2027 je
dis la France éimet tant desfitc par
habitant chers amis allemands chers amis
polonais le jour où vous serez notre
niveau nous reprendrons nos chemin avec
vous
rejoignez-nous parce que
l'escroquerie qui tue la France de
vouloir revenir à
1990 d'accord c'est l'escroquerie du
siècle puisque en 90 sur la base la
ligne de départ nous avions déjà
l'électricité nucléaire d'accord donc ça
veut dire que on demande à la France un
effort les - 55 % de gaz à effet de
serre par rapport à 1990 vous êtes bien
d'accord on demande à la France un
effort surhumain par rapport à des pays
comme l'Allemagne et la Pologne qui
étaient bien au-dessus ok donc attendez
non non j'insiste làessus donc je mais
c'est très important excusez-moi c'est
très important non non laissez-moi finir
au Françis
nous sommes le pays le plus exemplaire
en matière de gaz et effet de serre
admettons que tout ça existe et que ce
soit pas une Fouthèse intégrale
admettons accordons-nous sur ce
désaccord c'est ça non mais admettons
que ce soit ça la France est le pays le
plus exemplaire la France doit arrêter
cette obsession qui gaspille 40
milliards par an au budget déjà euh de
pseudo investissements dont l'utilité
marginale est nul quasi nul alors même
que en une journée les Chinois les
Polonais les Indiens font 10 fois plus
que nous donc il faut arrêter de
culpabiliser les Français les Français
première décision tiens si j'arrive au
pouvoir les 40 milliards pour la
transition écologique on arrête et on
attend que les Allemands soient à notre
niveau et là on reprendra ensemble dans
la joie et le bonheur dans 30 ans et ces
40 milliards déjà ils seront plus
endettés premier point oui mais on
arrête d'escroquer les Français
là-dessus les a feu à la con les DPE à
la con mais mais mais c'est pas possible
d'être aussi bête c'est du suicide
frçais alors oui quand il y aura un
désert qui aura plus d'activité
économique que tout le monde sera au
chômage et qu' aura plus rien et qu'on
sera colonisé alors on aura un effet de
ser parfait bah oui ça ça sera parfait
on va être colonisé par qui mais on sera
on sera les esclaves des
riches les esclaves des riches on sera
un zoo que voulez hcller pour la France
d'ailleurs les petites femmes de Paris
un bordel c'est ce que voulaz Hitler
pour la France c'est ce qu'on fait nos
dirigeants je me lâche parce que
l'mission passent mais c'est attendez
estceonut être ven c'est c'est c'est
très intéressant en ce moment on est en
train de bosser sur un sujet qui va
traiter de l'industrie du sexe c'est
très intéressant de voir des
nationalités qu'on ne voyait plus sur
l'industrie du sexe
réémerger ça prouve la santé économique
du pays d'ailleurs non mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que donc le le
réchauffement climatique la bombe
africaine donc admettons et
accordonsnous sur le le fait qu'il y a
un réchauffement climatique le
réchauffement climatique va impacter
énormément la zone sahélienne oui mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on laisse ses gens crever on leur
envoie de la clime on fait quoi c'est un
sujet qui est très sérieux je suis
d'accord
mais je me méfie beaucoup des scénarios
catastrophiques l'enjeu majeur de
l'Afrique c'est de développer déjà la
production agricole c'est ensuite de
transformer les matières premières et
que les pays d'Afrique se les
réapproprient et la France aurait pu
jouer ce rôle d'aide sincère mais ça
veut dire changer de politique mais ça
ve dire avoir une parole oui ça veut
dire avoir une parole mais dès qu'on
envoie monsieur barreau en Afrique
l'accord de coopération est rompu
puisqu'il vient donner des
leçons au chefs d'État africain donc
faudrait peut-être arrêter donc je crois
que l'Afrique est l'affaire peut-être la
plus importante c'est le défi le plus
important de notre siècle comment gérer
j'ai pas les Réponses à tout mais
comment gérer le doublement de la
population africaine d'après les
scénarios sur 30 ans ce qui est colossal
1 milillard 300 millions d'habitants en
plus comment on le gère il y a quelques
pistes des pistes ténues que j'ai
d'abord l'Afrique pourrait produire
beaucoup plus en matière agricole
beaucoup plus il faut l'aider pour ça
intelligemment ça vaut beaucoup plus que
tous les discours sur le réchauffement
climatique en Afrique ensuite il faut
voir comment les matière premières
peuvent être rétribué correctement et
transformé sur place ça serait déjà pas
mal ensuite il faut que les capitauxx
africain reste en Afrique et n'z pas à
Genève ou à Hong Kong ou à
Dubaï il y a quelques pistes comme ça
qu'on pourrait déjà faire voilà après
c'est pas moi qui vais régler le
problème de l'Afrique tout seul mais
déjà si on avait un discours rationnel
sur l'Afrique ça irait mieux donc je
vous je vous sens très anxieux sur le
sujet de grand remplacement selon vos
mots euh euh qu'est-ce qu'on fait selon
vous on construit des
murs vous parlez vous parlez de déployer
la la l'armée à nos frontières c'est
pour faire quoi l'armée à nos frontières
c'est pour envoyer un signal au
monde et à nos partenaires que la France
n'est plus une passoire que la France
contrôle les entrées évite les goofast
et les trafics de droguees monstrueux
que la police et la gendarmerie
aujourd'hui rien à voir ça bah si c'est
des frontières les frontières c'est pas
que l'immigration la frontière c'est les
activités délictueuses c'est les
délinquants c'est les trafiquants moi je
ne vois pas la frontière comme
simplement un problème migratoire un
pays a besoin de savoir ce qui rentre
sur son sol et ce qui en sort quand vous
avez des containerses qui arrivent de
Chine qui ne sont jamais contrôlés dans
les ports français et qui ont des
produits qui ne sont pas aux normes
européennes même même le normes
européennees qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
engage plus de douigners et ben on a des
scanners on a des douigners on contrôle
oui on contrôle on maîtrise mais sinon
on est il y a plus rien il y a plus de
pays donc je propose une reprise en main
pouvez considérer que c'est ringar moi
je veux une reprise en main moi quand
j'arrive à Riss j'ai
honte quand j'arrive dans un aéroport à
New York à Dubaï ou n'importe où il y a
un contrôle voilà il y a un pays là il y
a pas de pays c'est un
nomlandôles vous plaisentez vous avez vu
ce qu'il y a vous avez honte mais même
pour l'accueil c'est la honte parce que
ça veut dire qu'il y a plus d'État les
doers sont très sympas non mais c'est
pas la
question c'est pas la question c'est
qu'il faut qu'il soit soutenu qui a une
volonté qui a un
état reconstruire une démocratie
reconstruire un état reconstruire une
nation c'est du boulot qu'est-ce qu'on
fait selon vous avec les les questions
migratoires question
migratoires il y a tout voir il y aura
jamais d'immigration zéro et ce serait
absurde on n'est pas une boîte de
conserve mais on est passé à 300000 LEGO
150000 demandeurs
d'asile en gros 450000 Lego chaque
année plus les illégaux ce n'est pas
gérable ce n'est pas tenable donc il
faut ça vient d'où ces chiffres c'est
les chiffres 2023 vous retrouvez bah de
du ministère de l'Intérieur vous trouvez
les chiffres officiels vous ver vérifier
ou 3 qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les les
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça veut dire qu'on
réduit partout c'est-à-dire qu'on réduit
le regroupement familial on
réduit les visas on on réduit tout et
sur les demandeurs d'asile on les fait
dans les pays d'origine ou à nos
frontières dans des centres fermés de
manière à éviter que sur les 150000
demandeurs d'asile vous en ayez de
mémoire 50000 d'acceptés 100000 de
refusés mais sur les 100000 de refusés
vous en avez que 20000 qui sont expulsés
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les ooctf
c'est un sujet
qui mais vous savez pourquoi il y a des
qtf d'abord parce que une directive
adoptée par Nicolas Sarkozi européenne
la fameuse directive retour de 2009 ou
2008 euh a conduit François Hollande
pour la respecter à supprimer le délit
de séjour
irrégulier comme on ne peut plus
incarcérer quelqu'un pour délit de
séjour irrégulier pucequ'il y a plus de
délit de séjour irrégulier en vertu de
cette directive européenne voilà
pourquoi je veux en finir avec l'Union
européenne euh et retrouver droit
national l'agent de police délivre une
octtf mais que cette octtf est un bout
de papier la personne est
libre voilà pourquoi il y a tant d'qtf
jamais exécuté c'est que leqtf les
Français croient que c'est une
arrestation on a le délit il y a plus de
délit de séjourer régulier un clandestin
c'est quelqu'un qui rentre on lui
délivre un papier et ce papier ne sert à
rien puisque il faud faudrait l'arrêter
l'incarcérer le mettre dans un centre de
rétention l'expulser donc ça veut dire
qu'on ne maîtrise plus rien qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec les pays qui veulent pas
récupérer leur leur s représaille
immédiate représaille ce qu' a fait
Trump avec la Colombie ça a été très
vite et on fait quoi avec l'Algérie
alors on fait suppression des accord de
68 suppression de l'aide au
développement suppression des visas et
si vous voulez la bombe atomique vous
supprimez les Western Union des
Algériens qui renvoient de l'argent en
Algérie ça va très vite être réglé pas
compris là si vous voulez la bombe
atomique c'estàdire si vous voulezêtre
très ferme ah encore plus ferme mais
déjà de supprimer les visas pour les
dignitaires du régime qui viennent de se
faire soigner à Paris ça va les calmer
très vite et si nous disent bah notre
gaz vous pouvez vous bon le gaz on
s'assoit dessus il y a que j'ai plus les
chiffres mais je crois que c'est 6
milliards de mè CB ENF c'est ou 6 % on
peut tout à fait s'asseoir dessus
maintenant ça suffit la France c'est pas
un
paillasson et j'ajoute dernier point
très important sur l'Algérie
pardonnez-moi sur l'Algérie ce qui me
choque énormément c'est que Macron nous
dit ah oui mais il y a 900000 algériens
ou double nationalité en France mais
c'est une insulte aux
Algériens parce que les Algériens qui
sont en France ils sont en France parce
qu'ils connaissent le régime
algérien et même les Algériens d'Algérie
ils en peuvent plus de téboule les
compagnies et de toute cette clique qui
a pillé ce pays qui l'a détruit vous
avez des sources de ça ah bah vous
croyez queils sont populaires par
rapport au pillag vous avez des sources
ah bah Vous vous avez vu l'état de
l'Algérie qu'est-ce que produit
l'Algérie à part la rente pétrolière et
gazière c'est un fiasco intégral vous
avez vu l'opposition algérienne ils n'en
peuvent plus les Algériens de cette clic
et cette clic ne se maintient au pouvoir
que par la faiblesse française qui tend
l'autre jour régulièrement ça
suffit enfin je veux dire on est né
après les événements d'Algérie on va pas
vivre éternell dessus et le peuple
algérien mérite mieux je vous assure
donc moi je connais des Algériens dans
ma ville là hier j'ai des Algériens qui
me disent mais monsieur du poignant
comment votre pouvoir peut être aussi
faible à l'égard de cette bande de
bandit qui gouverne notre pays mais
pourquoi vous êtes aussi faible donc ça
fait partie de cette espèce de de
néopaternalisme de nos dirigeants à
l'égard des populations d'origine
étrangère française qui sont en France
ou qui sont françaises maintenant
moi je les considère soit en tant que
Français quelle que soit l'origine j'en
ai rien à faire parce que je les
considère comme français je suis
assimilationiste si en revanche il se
comporte mal il dégage je suis désolé je
ne considère que deux catégories de gens
ceux qui respectent la loi de la France
et ceux qui ne la respectent pas et je
rentre pas dans les histoires de charité
de néopaternalisme il est d'origine
algérienne donc il va pas être content
que je sois pas sympa avec le président
de l'Algérie mais enfin c'est quoi ça je
veux dire que les Algériens ou les
Français d'origine algérienne aimeraient
que l'Algérie soit un pays civilisé qui
reprennent les sont civilisés en Algérie
mais non il n'appliquent pas le droit
international ils reprennent pas leur
délinquants c'est le droit international
qu'on demande tout simplement avec la ch
et la France est tellement faible à
l'égard de tous les pays qu'elle n'est
plus respectée comme pays libre voilà
c'est tout on fait quoi avec la Chine
avec la Chine oui vaste programme
qu'est-ce qu'on fait bah d'abord si la
Chine nous avec nos petits bras on est
sorti ah commencez pas alors vous allez
pas commencer ce discours qui légitime
toutes les abandons qui est de dire on
est plus petit que les autres donc on se
couche on nexiste plus ça j'entends ça
depuis que j'ai 20 ans ça a été le
prétexte à l'Union européenne depuis 30
ans ah mais la France a 70 millions
d'habitants 68 qu'est-ce qu'elle peut
face un milliard bah oui mais alors
Singapour à 3 millions il en a combien
le Maroc on a combien l'Algérie on a
combien donc on supprime tous les pays d
pontignant il fait combien de
pourcentage il a pas le droit de se
présenter c'est la la fin même vous
faites pas 1,90 vous avez pas le droit
d'exister c'est ce que je vous ai dit
d'ailleurs dans une maternité ah bah le
le petit bébé qui nait il est un peu
petit allez h on le jette mais enfin
c'est quoi ce donc face à la Chine la
France est un pays libre qui doit
défendre ses intérêts coopérer selon ses
intérêts voilà voilà si la Chine ne sort
pas de ses frontières et respecte on n
pas l'agresser en revanche il est
inacceptable mais ça c'était évident
qu'en rentrant dans l'OMC avec un
système capitaliste étatiste
subventionné par le Parti communiste
mais les chinois ils ont raison les
autres ont été des des des il les a les
autres ont été naïfs c'est pas la faute
des chinois c'est la faute des
Occidentaux Taïwan c'est la Chine ou
c'est Taïwan ah vaste débat Taiwan c'est
la Chine ou c'est Taiwan c'est Taiwan
Taïwan c'est taiïwan taiïwan c'est
Taiwan donc Taïwan c'est pas la Chine
Taïwan c'est Taïwan c'est-à-dire un
statut embryonnaire qui a qui pour en
droit international est entre les deux
laissons Taïwan à Taïwan et comprenons
aussi que la Chine estime que c'est un
peu son Alsace Loren voilà comme Hong
Kong et il faudra trouver des compromis
sur tout ça je veux dire que
euh comment dire
il faut dans ces affaires comprendre
l'ensemble des données et puis adapter
notre politique en fonction de nos
intérêts voilà donc si je résume ça plus
trivialement c'est pardonnez-moi la
vulgarité c'est chacun pour soi et Dieu
pour tous exactement la France n'a que
des intérêts et n'a pas d'amis voilà et
moi mon boulot c'est défendre la France
qui est menacé de
disparition et j'en ai assez que des
dirigeants qui sont pas capables de
faire respecter l'ordre sur le
territoire français qui sont pas
capables de défendre notre industrie
française qui sont pas capable d'assurer
la justice sociale minimum c'est qu'on
les a laissé faire qui attendez donne
des leçons à la terre entière se mèle
des affaires de la terre entière mais
s'occupe pas de leurs affaires donc
lorsque Monsieur Macron aura rétabli
l'ordre dans nos cités il pourra
s'occuper de l'Ukraine de Taiwan et des
autres en attendant moi je préférais
qu'il s'occupe de la sécurité en France
avant de donner des leçons à la terre
entière on a une classe politique
hallucinante qui passe sa vie à faire
des commentaires sur la terre entière
mais qui est même pas capable de
s'occuper de ses
concitoyens voilà ce que je vous dis
donc je crois que l'urgence là je suis
isolationiste en ce moment l'urgence est
de s'occuper des Français avant qu'on
disparaisse ça va se matérialiser
comment notre disparition selon vous
mais je je la souhaite pas la
disparition la disparition elle est
progressive de 0 à 100 on est on est au
au pied du du mur pas au pied du mur
zéro zéro on est très loin et et 100 on
est on va voulez dire 100 on va bien ou
on va mal 100 on va très mal on est
à je dirais qu'on est à
78 entre 75 et 80 on peut aller encore
plus
mal qu'est-ce qui pourrait nous faire
aller plus
mal continuer ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui et peut-être que le moment
de bascule c'est la perte définitive de
souveraineté le choc démocratique
c'est-à-dire que je je vais au bout de
la pensée pour que parce que en disant
ça j'en vous dire ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire
que c'est le passage à la soumission à
la loi de la majorité au niveau de
l'Union européenne sur les questions
fondamentales de politique étrangère et
de défense qui engage la vie des
Français parce que si vous avez un
Allemand ou un Polonais qui considère
que l'intérêt vital de la force de
dissuasion européenne c'est le fait
qu'il y ait trois soldats russes au
donbas et bien on se oui enfin dans une
zone qui a été russe pendant 5
siècles si on considère que c'est ça et
qu'on va risquer la peau des Parisiens
des Strasbourgeois des rinnoir d'une
bombe atomique pour ça et ben j'estime
qu'on met en danger de mort la nation
parce que c'est curieux ce sont des gens
qui se révoltent et à juste titre parce
que moi je veux pas spécialement pour
que les Russes
ende n aucune
émotion auunemotion il faut nous battre
pour nos valeurs il faut qu'on aille
protéger les ukra mais la première des
valeurs c'est la valeur des Français
d'abord est-ce qu'on peut se battre un
jour pour les Français qui crèvent la
fin est-ce qu'on peut se battre pour les
Français qui se font agresser dans la
rue est-ce qu'on peut se battre pour les
Français qui souffrent est-ce que c'est
pas la première des valeurs quand même
des dirigeants politiques qui sont élus
par les Français voilà bien évidemment
que moi je souhaite que les valeurs
d'égalité triomphent partout mais je
suis désolé quand je vois le monde tel
qu'il est je me dis que si on veut faire
respecter un peu d'ordre international
et un peu de justice il faut que la
France existe mais à quoi ça sert c'est
comme si par exemple j'essaie de trouver
une
image c'est comme si un individu ne
mangeait plus ne s'alimentait plus ne
buvait plus pour faire la police dans
tout le quartier en apné on dirait mais
il est fou le mec donc occupons-nous
d'abord de notre pays qui est en train
de disparaître alors disparaître il va
pas disparaître comme comme parc
d'attraction bien sûr c'est c'est là où
où je dis esclave c'est pour ça qu'il
faut voter Philippe deviler comme ça on
aura un pu du fou à l'échelle nationale
voilà on va devenir un parc d'attraction
voilà alors il y aura des emplois de
serveur des emplois de un parc
d'attraction on racontera des belles
histoires voilà un parc d'attraction je
veux pas que ma France soit un parc
d'attraction la France ce qui ne
comprennent
pas parce que je peux paraître cynique à
ceux qui me regardent sur l'affaire de
taiïwan de l'Ukraine et cetera c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que bien
évidemment j'aimerais que la France que
le président français si j'étais
président français je rêverais bien sûr
d'aller dans tous les pays du monde dire
le droit la vérité la justice bon le
bien le mal mais pour faire ça faut être
de Gaul car dresser la France mais vu
dans la situation dans laquelle on est
je pense que la
priorité du chef d'État français que
j'aspire à être c'est de remettre de
l'ordre dans son pays de remettre en
fonctionnement l'économie française la
puissance
française c'est de colmater les brèches
et c'est de recréer un dynamisme
intérieur et puis après peut-être que 10
ans après on pourra aller faire les
marioles ici ou là donc d'une d'un coup
de baguette magique on vous voit
président de la République oui votre
Ministre des Finances c'est qui un petit
chef d'entreprise d'une PME un petit
chef d'entreprise d'une PME oui pour
mettre au pas Bercy d'accord et alors
pour partir non mais c'est c'est pas un
gadget pour partir de la production en
France c'est-à-dire appliquer le
programme qui est sur mon site internet
que vous pouvez trouver produire en
France où il y a un certain nombre de
mesures très très précise où tout doit
être fait pour produire en France
c'estàdire que les baisses de charges
qui ont été faites doit fait pour ceux
qui investissent en France pas pour ceux
qui impimportent et délocalisent ok donc
votre petit chef d'entreprise après on
peut en trouver plein ministre des
Finances ministre de l'économie de
l'économie et des finances je suis pas
sûr qu'il doit être ministre des
Finances je pense qu'il faut un ministre
de l'Économie fait comment pour aller
sur les marché pour refinancer la dette
française mais parce qu'à partir du
moment où vous allez avoir un pays tenu
avec un cap économique un cap économique
où on met fin aux dépenses inutiles déjà
ça chiffre à combien les dépenses alors
j'ai écrit un livre vous pouvez le
retrouver ouv poognon attendez je vais
vous répondre ou Val poognon ,90 aux
édition non 10 € pas cher exprès
audition l'archipel non mais je le dis
pour ceux qui veulent le lire ce non
mais attendez parce que c'est précis
j'ai repris tous les rapports
parlementaires de droite et de gauche
j'ai estimé à 50 milliards dépense qu'on
peut supprimer très rapidement sans
effet récessif excessif ça sans effet
récessif et ben c'est des dépenses qui
vont à l'extérieur du
pays parce que le drame aujourd'hui des
réductions de dépenses c'est qu'à chaque
fois que vous faites une très forte
réduction de dépenses vous cassez la
croissance et vous avez moins de recette
d'accord donc 10 milliards de moins pour
l'Union européenne j'arrête ça fait 10
milliards c'est pas négligeable l'arrêt
évidemment des aides à l'Ukraine on a
quand même donné 15 milliards là l'arrêt
desérê des pr un taux variable indexé
sur l'inflation on les lâche pas au
milieu du gay arrêtez pas un centime pas
un centime on a un plan de paix on
l'applique c'est fini moi j'alimente pas
la boucherie et je ne tue pas les
Ukrainiens avec des armes françaises et
les Russes avec des armes françaises la
la guerre on l'a fait totalement ou on
laa fait pas l'hypocrisie de ces
généraux de plateau non non attendez les
généraux de plateau qui sont dans des
jeux vidéos sur
LCI ça suffit une guerre c'est des êtres
humains
les Occidentaux ont cru qu'on
pouvait jouer avec la guerre c'est-àdire
envoyer les Ukrainiens se faire
massacrer avec des armes françaises ou
américaines surtout d'ailleurs 80 %
américaines enfin 63 % américaines 80 %
hors hors Europe non si on était honnête
soit on envoie des soldats français
mourir
là-bas soit on fait rien moi je suis
clair j'ai toujours dit dès le départ on
fait rien d'accord et si on avait un
petit gilet parbal non parce que si non
si on avait dit l'Ukraine non l'Ukraine
n'est pas dans l'OTAN oui des pansement
si vous voulez mais c'est la paix le
premier pensement c'est que si la France
si la France avait
dit jamais l'Ukraine sera dans l'OTAN
nous retirons les bases de la CIA de
l'Ukraine nous faisons un compromis sur
le Donbass avec statut d'autonomie
réelle que n'a jamais voulu voter
Zelenski au parlement ukrainien l'accord
de Minsk qui n'a pas été côté ukrainien
aussi ACC
Budapest les accords de Budapest
lesquels parce qu'il y en a eu lesquels
le premier le deuxème non mais lesquel
moi je est-ce que les accords du
Budapest ont été respectés vous voulez
dire sur l'avancée de l'OTAN en Pologne
sur le fait que les Russes aussi étaient
aussi
agressifs les Russes n'ont pas respecté
non plus j'ai jamais dit que les Russes
avaient raison sur tout j'ai dit qu'une
solution de paix était possible si les
français si la France ça avait été digne
et puis si elle avait échoué et ben
aujourd'hui elle récolterait la mise
quelle mise et ben la mise de symboliser
aux yeux du monde la voix de la paix
nous n'aurions pas perdu des des des
plumes en Afrique alors pourquoi nous
n'aurions pas eu la situation
d'aujourd'hui et nous aurions une
capacité de nous réconcilier avec la
Russie qui est notre avenir énergétique
et nos matières rares pourquoi pourquoi
pas le dire personne n'ose le dire
pourquoi je préfère dépendre je je veux
partager les dépendances je veux de la
réale politique alors la ré dépend
uniquement de la Chine vous croyez que
c'est bon ça dépend ah bon en quoi c'est
bon dépendre de la Chine bah on met
notre pollution chez eux on
on che eux donc pas les rivières qui
changent attendez moi je veux pas le la
misère pour la Chine je veux localise
notre pollution mais je ne veux pas de
ça non plus ça n fait des beauchit mais
attention les chinois sont pas idiots
ils se développent ah bien sûr qu's sont
pas idiots les Chinois les Chinois nous
ont revenons à nous moutons pourquoi
selon vous selon vous si je vous ai bien
on a fait de d'itération en itération
oui de digression en digression oui on
est où là on va revenir sur l'Ukraine
oui ah décidment si je vous écoute bien
les Ukrainiens ont été les proxis des
États-Unis oui complètement mais
complètement alors pourquoi parce que
les Américains théori de brzanski ont
toujours voulu couper l'Allemagne et la
France et l'Italie de la Russie c'est
tout et ils y ont réussi alors
pourquoi on a laissé faire ça parce que
nos
dirigeant européens étai totalement
soumis aux Américains de Biden soumis
AUC ou rincé oh j'ai pas d'éléments qui
me permettent de le dire non moi j'ai
jamais fait de calomnie là-dessusis
soumis vous savez là aussi je je pense
qu'il y a pas que la corruption loin de
là il y a aussi ce qui pense c'est tout
il raisonne comme un W démocrate de
l'Université de Stanford ou de ou de
Colombia non mais je veux dire il y a
pas toujours je crois qu'il faut faire
attention parce que moi j'ai vu tous ces
personnes depuis 30 ans faut pas croire
que je veux dire attention à pas tomber
pour le coup dans un complotisme de
bazar qui voudrait voir tous les gens
corrompus ces êtres humains ont une
pensée ils pense que camela Haris elle
était peut-être pas géniale mais c'était
génial parce qu'elle ffendait des
valeurs euh contre l'extrême droite euh
voilà c'est des gens sincères je veux
dire moi j'ai ma sincérité eux ils ont
la leur simplement je pense qu'ell nous
mettent dans le fossé de l'histoire et
j'essaie d'alerter et c'est ça la
démocratie moi je prétends pas être le
seul à avoir la vérité incarnée j'ai une
vérité se vous êtes peut-être pas le
seul à aler ils ont des
convictions leur modèle c'est ils sont
dans un modèle américain W démocrate de
la côtest voilà OK et donc ils ont suivi
donc ça c'est le modèle de Brezinski
c'est ça si je vous suis bien enfin
c'est pas le modèle de brzinski c'est
plus compliqué que ça c'est Brezinski ça
a toujours été l'inquiétude de voir
l'Europe occidentale et notamment
Schroder qui était quand même très
proche des Russes aussi s'agit pas de
tomber sous l'prise russe attention mais
les Américains ont toujours compris que
un gaz pas cher mais il y a même des
intérêts économiques les Américains
maintenant vendent leur gaz quatre fois
plus cher du du GNL gaz naturel liqufié
quatre fois plus le prix du gaz russe
ils ont quand même c'est quand même
génial d'arriver à vendre quatre fois le
prix un
produit c'est il y a pas beaucoup de
dans dans leshistoire économique du
monde il y a pas beaucoup de d'exemple
d'un marché gagné par un produit quatre
fois plus cher non mais est-ce que vous
avez ça dans l'histoire du
monde je crois pas revenons revenons à
non mais c'est la vous savez il y a pas
que des grands complots il y a que des
histoires de fric ons à votre ministre
de l'économie et des finan oui on en
était là pu on a dérapé de il fait
comment pour se refinancer sur les
marchés j'en étais là à partir du moment
où il y a une tête une politique et
qu'on l'explique en disant la France va
un faire des économie très forte non
récessive non récessive au moins 50
milliards et 100 très vite notamment si
j'arrête toutes les subventions pour la
transition écologique d'un coup 40
milliards plus mes 50 allez 80 90
milliards on peut réduire de moitié très
vite le déficit budgétaire c'est quoi
très vite en 2 ans mais le général de
Gaulle en 58 a redressé la France très
vite vous savez les marchés ils
regardent les réalités ils verront que
tiens il y a des gens censés deuxème
point une vraie politique de baisse des
charges des impôts de production des
baisses des charges du prix de
l'électricité pour doper l'industrie
française ça va faire ses produits très
vite donc ainsi la
relocalisation troisièmement une vraie
politique éducative où on apprend à lire
à nos enfants combien les profs et on va
les payer mieux combien ah actuellement
c'est le plus mal payé d'Europe mais
revalorisez les salaires des profs de
combien le chiffre le chiffre estimé
pour remettre au niveau moyen
européen au niveau moyen européen est de
10 milliards par an c'est énorme donc on
pourra pas le faire d'un coup mais déjà
si on pouvait récompenser les
professeurs qui vestisse plus si on
pouvait remettre la méthode syllabique
pour apprendre à lire si on pouvait
réapprendre la dictter si on pouvait
réapprendre le calcul et si on pouvait
avoir des élèves qui sortent du primaire
en sachant articuler tris mots on aura
fait beaucoup pour la France comment on
gère l'inertie qu'on a pris de l'inertie
éducative qu'on a pu prendre il faudra
15 ans puce qu'il faut tout le système
colaire faut le reconstruire le système
pénitentier vous sous votre mandature
vous allez le j'ai tout écrit là-dessus
on a un programme très précis sur
Internet 40000 places de prison en
réhabilitant les casernes désaffectéses
en faisant travailler les prisonniers en
leur faisant payer la journée de prison
en interdisant les portables à la prison
voilà euh et c'est pas encore les
boulets au pied et puis en renvoyant les
étrangers délinquants dans leur prison
et si possible en signant des accords
avec nos amis marocains algériens pour
qu'ils puissent passer leur peine de
prison dans les prisons marocaines
algériennes et là je pense que très vite
très vite ça s'arrangera croyez-moi
quand vous étiez venu la première fois
il y a un peu moins de 10 ans ouais on
avait discuté de la politique contre les
narcot trfic votre exemple numéro 1
c'était dourt oui et ben maintenant
c'est chercher quand même pour pas mal
s'est fait attraper je crois comment d't
il s'est pas fait attraper pour si un
peu mais enfin il en a quand même
expédié pas mal donc votre politique
contre lesi Salador Salvador Salvador
c'estd que on fait le Salvador chez nous
on les envo au Salvador exctement non on
fait le Salvador chez nous je vous
provoque un peu on fera jamais le
Salvador chez nous en France
rassurez-vous mais je veux
dire réforme du Code pénal par
référendum par référendum cinq
référendum les dans premier quinquena il
la peine de mort dedans non réforme du
Code pénal jeux pasouvrir le débat sur
la peine des morts c'est un débat
philosophique existentiel qui va
remuer tout un pays
catholique tu ne tueras point enfin moi
j'ai pas envie de rouvrir tout ça je
pense qu'il faut éviter les débats
passionnels croyez en Dieu oui mais je
veux éviter les débats passionnels donc
ça sert à rien il y a suffisamment de
problèm pour pas en rajouter donc
simplement déjà un système pénitentiaire
où l'État se fe respecter où les
gardiens de prison soient pas insultés
où on supprime les sorties les vacances
les
voyages on revient allez au système même
espagnol ou
anglais si déjà on pouvait rattraper nos
voisins européens
parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est hallucinant ce qui se passe en
prison c'est personne ne peut imaginer
ce qui se passe vous avez visité des
prisons oui bien sûr bien sûr je me
souviendrai toujours de la prison de
Villepinte où la directrice de la prison
très sympa d'ailleurs m'expliquait que
pour le quartier des mineurs où ça
sentait que le cheit parce que je savais
qu'il fallait y aller elle voulait pas
que j'y aille ça puait le cheit les
hurlements et tout et les gardiens de
prison on les avait déshabillé si je
puis dire pour les mettre en survette
parce que fallait être copain avec les
délinquants qui avaient violé tué
et cetera parce que le quartier des
mineurs d'une prison française c'est
vraiment des types qu'on fait du mal et
les pauvres gardiens de prison étaient
mis en survêtement blanc pour jouer les
copains et ça puit le chi dans toute la
prison non mais attendez enfin je veux
dire que si les Français savaient ce qui
se passe dans les prisons françaises
comment comment l'État parleit du fait
queon soit condamné depuis X années pour
mauvais traitement dans les prisons
parce que on est trop surchargé gens
dorment par qu'il y a eu un T d'humilité
vous avez raison oui mais ça c'est fini
il y a eu quand même d'énorm non
attendez deux choses il y a deux choses
il y a eu d'énormes efforts et c'est
vrai que l'état des prisons françaises
était lamentable mais il y a eu
d'énormes efforts de fait en revanche où
vous avez raison c'est qu'il y a une
surpopulation carcérale parce qu'on
s'est refusé à construire les places
parce qu'il y a un côté dans la culture
française politique et journalistiqueune
prison c'est sale bien sûr que c'est
triste mais la délinquent c'est encore
plus triste une femme
violée un enfant assassiné des gens
dépouillés c'est encore plus triste que
la prison donc il y a un moment moi j'en
peux plus cette inversion des valeurs
c'est-à-dire que il faut de la
réinsertion bien évidemment il faut
l'ensemble et pourquoi j'avais parlé de
40000 places de prison parce que ça
permettait de gérer la surpopulation
d'avoir un individu par cellule à terme
pour leur donner une chance il s'agit
pas de d'aller au fond de la mine et
puis ensuite d'avoir une vraie tâche de
réinsertion donc il s'agit pas de tomber
d'un excès à l'autre mais aujourd'hui ce
sont les caïdes qui font la loi en
prison c'est clair c'est net on le
sait revenons à la géopolitique
oui si Emmanuel Macron ou l'Union
européenne déclare la guerre à la Russie
h HM ou si il y a tellement de friction
au frontières ukrainiennes que on part
en guerre avec contre la Russie
qu'est-ce que vous ferezv
ah ben je dirais de toutes mes forces
que c'est une folie vous vous engagerez
oh je vais passé l'âge mais si j'avais
été plus jeune je
m'engageraiis je suis profondément
patriote donc je ne peux pas appeler à
la désobéissance comme responsable
public mais je ferai tout pour empêcher
cette guerre tout comment tout ce que je
peux tout ce que je peuximolation devant
l'Assemblée nationale non rassurez-vous
je ne ferai jamais ce plaisir à mes amis
et à mes ennemis euh non ce que je fais
aujourd'hui c'està-dire de de tout faire
pour d'abord rappeler ce qu'est la
guerre la monstruosité de la guerre le
fait qu'il y a des besoins sociaux
considérables il y a une sorte
d'excitation malsine euh en ce moment
sur la guerre sur l'armée Dieu sait si
je suis pas suspect d'être pacifiste et
j'ai toujours demandé qu'on ait un
effort de défense mais je veux pas qu'on
dépasse 3 % il est hors de question de
mettre 5 % de notre PIB dans la défense
alors qu'il y a tant de besoins sociaux
éducatifs universitaire de recherche
c'est pas parce qu'on produira des chars
à outrance alors que les drones sont
l'armée de demain et puis qu'il y aura
autre chose que les drones après-demain
qu'on va y arriver il y a une sorte de
lobby quand même de l'industrie de
défense qui est malsin en ce moment
oui l'argent l'argent roi sur l'emprunt
donc il faut arrêter il faut calmer le
jeu
et puis on va déclarer la guerre à la
terre entière non parce que on commence
par la Russie c'est oui B bien sûr et
pourquoi pas les autres l'Algérie l'Iran
la Turquie non mais tous les pays qui ne
sont pas comme nous j'écouté tiens il y
a pas longtemps madame
l'inénarable comment elle s'appelle elle
a un nom comment ah il y a Valerie aillé
qui est inénarable et dangereuse mais il
y a l'oiseau aussi qui est pas triste et
j'ai écouté madame l'oiseau dans une
émission du dimanche et en fait elle
était en guerre contre la terre entière
oui mais d'accord moi j'ai pas de mais
MBS en Arabie Saoudite c'est peut-être
pas la tasse de thé ce qui se passe
entre Israël et Gaza c'est abominable
euh pourquoi les pour parler SAF en
Arabie Saoudite et pas en France ben
parce que la France n'a plus de
politique étrangère la France n'est plus
indépendante la France n'est plus un
pays libre voilà c'est tout parce que la
France n'a pas pris la bonne décision en
fait c'est même pire que ça c'est parce
que la France ne pense plus le monde
en fait il faut fr pas la France le
gouvernement français ENF ceux qui ont
en charge la France ne pensent plus le
monde ils ne pensent même plus leur
politique
intérieure ils sont tellement en manchés
dans l'Union
européenne qu'ils ont été
infantilisés regardez ce qui se passe
dans les ministères c'est très
intéressant les ministères n'ont plus de
pensée autonome ils se faire à Bruxelles
vous avez 66000 fonctionnaires au niveau
de Bruxelles de l'Union européenne qui
ont eu augmentation de oui qui ont une
augmentation de salaire délirante qui
pensent notre destin parce que les
Français enfin les dirigeants français
ne le pensent plus il pensent plus le
monde quelle est la position de la
France sur chacun des sujets
internationaux un jour j'avais vu et
pour le coup on peut ne pas l'aimer mais
j'avais été reçu comme chef de parti par
Laurent fabu ministre des Affaires
étrangères j' avais été j'avais fait un
texte avec Henry tle qui était mon
délégué national de Debout la France aux
Affaires étrangères et nous avions eu
une heure d'entretien et on peut tout
dire de fabus tout dire de fabus mais on
avait eu une heure d'entretien on avait
balayé les cinq continents en une heure
je lu avais apporté un papier et j'ai d
voilà la pensée que j'ai de la politique
étrangère de la France après elle est
peut-être pas bonne elle est peut-être
bonne je me trompe peut-être DESS tout
bon je peux me planter mais voilà l'idée
que j'ai on avait une vraie discussion
passionnante vous imaginez faire ça avec
Monsieur Jean-Noël barreau
ou avec Monsieur
séjourné ou avec qui a eu avant je sais
même plus qui a eu je sa même plus bon
un ministre qui est mis en examen dans
votre gouvernement il fait quoi il
dégage présomption d'innocence non il
dégage non il dégage il a le temps de se
protéger il a le temps de se je suis sur
la jurisprudence balure point point ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il est coupable
mais on doit ça aux Français
écoutez nos compatriotes ils se lèvent
le matin ils se payent du moins ceux de
ma ville à hier dans les
sones ils prennent le bus dont un sur de
n'arrive pas à l'heure donc il loupe le
train après il se paye le r don un sur
de est en retard
ils arrivent à la défense 1 heure et
quart après pour
travailler ils ont pas eu d'augmentation
de salaire alors que les patrons ont eu
des stock options des bonus et Machin
depuis 4 ans pas tous les patrons
attendez toutes les grandes entreprises
d'cord ça représente pas tout oui oui en
attendant les salariés sont un pouvoir
d'achat qui diminue et ceux qui dirigent
ont toujours des augmentations c'est la
réalité il rentrent le soir il courent
pour aller à la crèche chercher leur
gamin il y a une crèche oui et encore
nous il y a des bonnes crèches euh ils
rentrent ils font le truc ils ont la
bouffe ils ont t au supermarché tout est
hors de prix je fais mes courses j'adore
faire mes courses ma femme aime pas moi
j'adore pour quoi parce que je rencontre
des gens parce que je regarde les je
regarde les produits parce que j'aime
bien ça me distrait voilà je le fais pas
tous les jours parce que ma femme si
elle voit l'émission elle va me dire tu
tu es gonflé bon mais votre pécher
mignon dans un supermarché marché
d'acheter du chocolat mais c'est ma
drogue ça va encore par rapport à
d'autres euh bon euh euh je car pure au
chocolat noir mais j'essaie d'arrêter
bromine c'est ça je sais pas mais ça me
dope le matin euh et bon bref tout ça
pour dire que les gens ils ont des vies
pas faciles ça veut pas dire qu'ils ont
des vies dures tous mais ils ont la vie
quotidienne de tous les Français quand
j'ai élevé mes enfants je sais ce que
c'est vous avez vos gamins votre boulot
pas beaucoup de sous le crédit tout et
il voit à la télé des mecs qui sont mis
en examen et qui continue à narguer les
gens mais comment voulez-vous qu'il a
une cohésion d'un pays comment
voulez-vous qu'il y ait une relation de
confiance comment voulez-vous qu'on
construise quelque choses ensemble vous
pouvez me mettre demain matin à l'Élysée
rien ne changera si j'ai pas la
confiance des Français rien ne
changera pourquoi j'ai parlé dans mon
discours de un électrochoc
indépendantiste un électrochoc
démocratique
parce que on ne redressera pas le pays
sans les Français et si on n'arrive pas
par des gestes symboliques que j'ai fait
moi dans ma ville quand j'ai été élu
j'ai été élu dans une ville où il y
avait eu beaucoup de malhonnêteté c'est
pour ça qu'on m'a élu d'ailleurs à 34
ans euh qui était en faillite et la
première chose que j'ai fait c'est tout
con hein c'est que quand j'arrive dans
un commerce je vais vous raconter ça
j'arrive dans la boulangerie et la
boulangère me dit alors Monsieur le
Maire une petite tarte moi je dis oui
tiens elles ont ver bon à gauche ou à
droite une petite tartelette euh ah bah
oui volontiers puis je dis combien je
vous dois ah bah non c'est rien j'ai dis
pardon ah bah votre prédcessur n'a
jamais payé ses gâteaux c'est normal
vous êtes Le Maire j'ai dis mais vous
vous vous plaisantez j'ai dis jamais
vous me ferez ça je payerai mes gâteaux
quoi qu'il arrive pareil pour tout euh
j'allais au McDo ou à une pizzeria pour
déjeuner j'ai annulé tous les frais tous
les on a fait une cure de rigueur on a
c'était pas pour l'argent économisé
unee importance c'était quoi non mais
par rapport au budget de la ville c'est
pas trois resto et qui changeit quoi que
ce soit c'est des restos à 1500 balles
non mais c'est mon prédécesseur faisait
pas des restos à 1500 balles quand même
mais c'était si vous voulez au-delà de
l'honnêteté il y a
l'exemplarité s'il y a pas d'exemplarité
il peut pas y avoir de cohésion s'il y a
pas de cohésion il y a pas d'effces il y
a pas d'effort il y a pas de résultat
voilà et ce qui me choque dans le
capitalisme actuel tel qu'il fonctionne
c'est ces grands chefs
d'entreprise qui s'arrochent des profits
hallucinants avec une bonne conscience
incroyable et
qui demande à leurs salariés de faire
des efforts ça c'est un truc qui me
dépasse parce que quand on est chef
d'entreprise si on veut que sa boîte
marche c'est normal qu'un chef
d'entreprise soit mieux payé qu'un
ouvrier c'est tout à fait normal mais
c'est pas
normal que les profits ne soient pas
répartis de manière égale et voilà
pourquoi je crois C mordicus à la
participation de l'entreprise je crois
que c'est la grande réforme
révolutionnaire à mettre en œuvre un
jour que n'a pas pu faire de goal vous
mettez qui en ministre de l'Intérieur et
pour quelle
direction bon un homme politique
honnête ferme droit juste voilà pas
xénophobe attention encore heureux non
mais comment je dis pas xénophobe bien
évidemment mais ce que je veux dire
qui n'a pas tendance à tout voir sous
l'angle de
l'immigration parce que il faut être
très ferme sur
l'immigration clandestine et délinquante
mais il ne faut pas voir toute la
société française sur l'immigration
parce que sinon on en arrive à à une
espèce d'enchaînement malsin qu'il y a
en France aujourd'hui où chacun se croit
maltraité par l'autre et où il y a une
espèce de surenchère qui peut aboutir un
jour à une déflagration grave
si vous avez une déflagration grave à
gérer tel que des banlieux qui
s'enflamment des gilets jaunes qui
s'enflamme c'est pas du tout la même
chose c'est pas la même chose donc les
gilets jaunes ont fait quoi et les
banlieux ont fait
quoi les gilets jaunes ils ont été
massacrés par le
pouvoir monsieur Castaner ne m'a jamais
été au bout de la diffamation quand j'ai
dit les petits attention hein on s'en
fit pas
il vous il vous attrape peut-être non
non mais je me souviens très bien qu'au
moment non mais au moment de
l'affaire souvenez-vous de l'affaire de
l'AC de Triomphe vous vous
souvenez j'ai été en salle des quatre
colonnes vous savez à l'Assemblée où il
y a toutes les caméra et j'ai dit les
petits casseurs de Monsieur Castaner
parce que je trouvais que ça rimait bon
il av pas de casseur de Castaner là
attendez j'ai dit les petits casseurs de
Monsieur castanaer ça vous fait marrer
oui ça me fait marrer parce que tout le
monde a cru que j'avais des information
absolument extraordinaire j'avais
quelques
informations qui provenait d'où qui
provenait du ministère de l'Intérieur et
j'avais les petits casseurs de Monsieur
Castaner mais quand j'ai dit ça j'ai
plus dit ça s la boutade et le mot m'a
échappé parce que tous les gens croient
que les hommes politiques calculent tout
mais les hommes politiques sont parfois
un peu fanfaron et parfois on se laisse
aller à une petite phrase bon tolé
général monsieur Castaner convoque une
conférence de presse quand même pour une
phrase et dit je vais attaquer en
diffamation monsieur Dupont pour ses
accusations graves pourquoi vous faisiez
des accusations qui en disant les petits
casseurs de Monsieur Castaner je
sous-entendais qu' avait des éléments
perturbate qu'il y avait des éléments
perturbateurs qui visaient à discréditer
le mouvement des gilets jaunes et que
les incidents de l'Arc de Triomphe
n'étaiit pas seulement le fait des
gilets jaunes c'était clairement de la
diffamation sauf qu'il n'a jamais
attaqué en diffamation mais pourquoi
parce que il pensait que j'avais des
informations
particulières et que devant un tribunal
et bien peut-être qu'il il aurait eu des
informations que les Français ne
devaient pas
savoir Monsieur benala s'il avait pas
été pris étaé un petit castaneur un
petit casseur de Monsieur Macron mais
mais n'importe quoi pourquoi vous dites
ça bah parce que je dis que Monsieur
benala il a fait quoi le scandale benala
c'était quoi qu'il occupait la fonction
de policier alors qu'il était pas
policier oui et puis qui cassait la
gueule quand même des gens dans une
manif pour créer le bazar c'est bien
connu bref pourquoi je vous raconter ça
je vous raconter ça pour dire que j'ai
une idée de l'ordre public qui est de la
fermeté mais de la légalité et la
justice et que ce qui a été fait au
leader des gilets jaunes est ind digne
de notre République c quoi vos
informations concernant l'Arc de
Triomphe j'en dirais pas plus puisque
l'affaire est pass soit vous en dit trop
ou soit pas non je dis que j'avais des
échos qu'il y avait des manipulations
des bruit de couloir c'est quoi c'est
des informations que j'ai eu avec des
personnes censées que je connais mais
qui occupent quel poste qui sont partis
maintenant depuis longtemps c'était des
gens qui étaient sur le terrain ouis non
mais d'accord il a pas porté plainte
d'accord voilà ça été un grand ministre
de l'Intérieur qui se reconvertit vous
savez
où voilà comme quoi l'argent n'a pas
d'odeur il peutêtre est peutêtre en
train de bosser dur ah mais sûrement
très dur apporter des ministre de la
Santé vous faites quoi s'il y a une
pandémie qui débarque je nomme monsieur
Peron ministre de la santé ou monsieur
Rault
oui je nomme monsieur Peron et Monsieur
Raoul tu grand
scientifique parce que le ce qui est
insupportable dans ce qui s'est
passé c'est que on a S des scientifiques
et on a fait passer des charlatans pour
des scientifiques et on a accusé de
complotistes des gens qui se basaient
sur des données scientifiques donc je
mets des grands scientifiques à la tête
du ministère de la Santé ministre des
Armées vous mettez qui
il faudra voir
qui pour faire quoi une stratégie de
défense qui vient d'être publiée sur mon
site internet puisque je l'ai
réactualisé avec justement un partiprix
original par rapport à tout ce qu'il
voit dans le monde politique qui est de
dire la France ne pourra pas tout faire
je ne veux pas qu'on dérape avec des
dépenses trop importantes parce que nous
avons des besoins sociaux des besoins de
défense des besoins euh éducatifs des
besoins scientifiques et que nous avons
un déficit budgétaire colossal donc 2
et5 % du PIB pas plus on concentre sur
la force de dissuasion et son
actualisation notamment les fameux
missiles hypersoniques on concentre sur
la Marine nationale parce que nous avons
des intérêts dans le monde et notamment
les territoires d'autres m et on
concentre sur les technologies d'avenir
cyberespace espace point en revanche on
ne cède pas à ceux qui veulent qu'on
rentre dans une armée de ce qu'ils
appellent de de grande intensité
c'est-à-dire pour envoyer des chars en
Allemagne et en Pologne ça c'est le
boulot des Polonais et des
Allemands c'està-dire on évite de tout
faire en terme de renseignement on fait
quoi on investit aussi dans le
renseignement bien évidemment c'est ce
que j'appelle le cyber et l'espace
j'aurais pu l'ajouter j'en suis désolé
si vous deviez déf et vous avez tout sur
le site internet on vient de le réécrire
si vous aviez 2 minutes pour défendre
Macron qu'est-ce qu'il a bien
fait ense de son intérêt personnel et la
manipulation de l'opinion un génie mais
il a un génie de la manipulation de
l'opinion il a peut-être fait quelque
chose de bien non un génie de la
manipulation de l'opinion il aura fait
tellement de mal à la France quand je
pense qu'on m'a assassiné parce que j'ai
voulu j'ai soutenu avec et je Marine Le
Pen en 2017 et en
2022 quand je pense l'infamie qu' a subi
pour le coup je suis en désaccord avec
elle en ce moment parce que je je la
trouve pas assez opposante
euh mais quand je pense que c'est subi
pour avoir choisi justement le bon sens
et le bilan qu'il y a mon Dieu parce que
jamais entre
nous jamais j'aurais pu imaginer en 2017
qu'on vive l'infamie du traitement des
gilets jaunes par la
police l'infamie du traitement du covid
et les milliers de morts dans les
personnes dans les dans
les dans les épades qui auraient pu être
soigné avec de l'hivvermectine ou avec
de l'hydroxychloroine et jamais j'aurais
pu croire qu'on puisse vivre ce qu'on
vit sur la peur de la guerre pour
détourner des vrais problèmes du pays la
faillite financière la faillite
éducative la faillite des services
publics le problème d'uneimmigration le
problème de la sécurité jamais j'aurais
pu croire ça juste une parenthèse jamais
j'aurais pu croire ça y a eu des et
c'est ce qui me rend combatif vous savez
il y a eu des études sur l'ivermectine
qui fonctionnaent par qui évidment mais
bien évidemment par qui mais il y a il y
a 216 études vous allez sur Internet
hivermectine machin vous avez tout ça a
été utilisé dans quantité de pay non
mais il y a un site j'ai pu en tête le
nom du site mais vous trouvez sur
internet il y a des centaines d'études
sur l'ivermectine j'ai moi-même été
soigné àivvermectine j'ai fait un
jogging après TR une semaine de de covid
c'est c'est un traitement
antiparasitaire c'est un traitement
alors c'est pas qu'ivvermectine sol
c'est hivermectine aitroméine très fort
antibiotique
cortisone je l'ai donné sous la sous le
manteau j'ai sauvé quelques personnes
vous avez pas le droit de faire ça non
mais je l'ai fait parce que quand il
s'agit de la vie de la mort de quelqu'un
moi je le fais j'en ai rien à [__] et
heureusement j'avais des pharmaciens
sympas qui m'ont alimenté et vous savez
ce qui est intéressant j'en ai rien à
faire quand il s'agit de sauver une
vie j'ai sauvé des vies et je vais vous
dire ce qui est intéressant c'est que
euh tout bib non mais j'ai sauvé des
vies avec des tbim je suis pas tbim je
me serai jamais permis euh euh mais j'ai
un jour j'étais aux États-Unis je
voulais rencontrer Ron Johnson qui est
un grand sénateur et qui a eu une
période aussi comme moi très euh à
défendre la liberté pendant la période
de covid la liberté de soin j'ai jamais
forcé les gens à prendre un médicament
la liberté de soin le serment
d'Hippocrate
euh et un jour je il pouvait pas me
recevoir il était en pleine campagne et
puis il m'a dit qu'un un cop
membre du Congrès républicain du Texas
et on fait une visio et c'était
fascinant et le type me raconte vous
savez moi j'ai envoyé des paquets
d'ivermectine en avion par un copain qui
avait un avion à des amis dans l'État de
New York parce que l'État de New York
sous la pression de Biden ils avaient
interdit l'ivermectine donc moi je
faisais des cargaisons d'hivermectine
pour sauver mes potes un un républicain
un membre du Congrès et j'ai dit mais
c'est incroyable moi je faisais la même
chose en France
et là la victoire de Kennedy aux
États-Unis est miraculeuse je sais pas
combien de temps il va tenir pourquoi
miraculeuse parce que cet homme a écrit
un livre je vous invite à le lire
absolument remarquable sur faosi plus
grand ESCR qui a fait tant de mal à
l'humanité et et on a fait passer cet
homme pour un complotiste charlatan
machin alors que il veut défendre la
santé des Américains contre les
marchands de mort et de poison c'est pas
que des marchands de mort et pas que des
marchands de poison
ce sont des marchands de mort et de
poisons je peux pas vous laisser dire ça
mais moi je le pense donc je vous dis ce
que je pense si vous m'invitez c'est
pour dire ce que je pense ils ont eu
peut-être des problèmes avec Kennedy
avec certaines communautés qui se
vaccinent pas ils ont pas un retour de
la polio ou un retour de quelque chose
comme ça là attendez alors soyons clair
il y a des vaccins utiles j'ai jamais
été contre la vaccination jamais mes
enfants sont vaccinés je suis pas un
antivaccin vous êtes vacciné contre le
covid jamais et heureusement
j'ai sauvé ma
peau regardez le dernier livre de
Monsieur chillot sur les victimes du
vaccin colossal à l'échelle de l'Europe
colossal c'est sourcé c'est carré c'est
sourcé archicarré c'est un statisticien
c'est impressionnant je viens de le lire
connais pas monsieur chillot vous
vérifierez ça vient de sortir livre très
documenté après chacun fait son dîné
question internet sur quels arguments
repos ces croyances médicales entre
guillemets mais sur la
science sur la
science sur les soins il y a eu des
centaines
d'études regardez l'étude comme regardez
quand même sur l'affaire moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup patriillé parce que moi j'étais
pas médecin moi je suis renseigné vous
voulez toujours pas mais mais moi j'ai
j'ai observé moi j'ai je pas là pour je
suis pas médecin mais en revanche j'ai
pas je voulais que je vous raconte une
anecdote vous avez observé les médecins
mais non mais j'ai observé les soins
j'ai observer les résultats regardez
l'étude de monsieur raou qui a été
calomnié quand vous pensez que
l'industrie pharmaceutique a organisé
une fausse étude pour discréditer
l'hydroxychlorquine qui allait donner
des arrêts cardiaques alors que ça é
utilisé dans le monde entier évidemment
à bonne dose si vous prenez du dolipran
pas la bonne dose vous avez aussi mais
vous êtes malade comment il a été sali
il a fait une étude sur 30000 soins
30000 malades qui montre à quel point
l'U de Marseille a eu de meilleur
résultat queà Paris quand vous voyez
l'hiver mectine les études dans le monde
entier qu'il a eu dans des états de
l'Inde au Japon prix Nobel c'est un prix
Nobel qui a inventé l'hivermectine qui a
été utilisé il y a un moment il y a il y
a des faits et quand vous voyez que tout
a été fait pour qu'on soigne pas les
gens et vous savez pourquoi vous savez
quelle est la loi américaine ah mais
pourquoi c'est que vous
pouvez commercialiser un vaccin sans les
l'ensemble des phases d'étude s'il n'y a
pas de traitement alternatifs donc il
fallait tuer les traitements alternatifs
pour pouvoir sortir les vaccin avant le
délai de précaution c'est tout on arrive
à la fin la une des plus grandes
escroqueries de l'humanité de santé
public je sais que j'aiété très critiqué
je sais que j'ai perdu des voies
là-dessus j'ai encore des gens que je
rend compte qui me disent monsieur
dupontignant je vous aime beaucoup tout
machin mais alors vos positions j'ai dis
mes positions vous les avez entendu par
qui quel et vous les connaissez mes
positions vous avez lu mes positions
vous avez écouté mes vidéos jusqu'au
bout ah non j'ai entendu que vous étiez
antivax
jamais été antivax le vaccin ARN n'a pas
le recul nécessaire j'ai simplement dit
ça on arrive à la fin de notre interview
est-ce que vous avez tro livres à
conseiller à notre communauté
ah TR livres à
conseiller le livre de Bruno LEM
forcément lequel parce qu'il a tellement
eu de livre de
cul les mémoires d'Adrien
deursenard que j'aime beaucoup
parce
que j'ai alors ça va vous
surprendre j'ai un film à vous
conseiller voyz j'y pense tout à coup
vous me demandez un livre le sel de la
terre de Vim vender c'est de
Salgado sur l'humanité sur le la
monstruosité des guerres de la misère
c'est un des plus beaux films qui existe
et pour moi c'est aussi important qu'un
livre le sel de la terre et puis alors
des livres a
tellement le dernier livre de
Villepin non non non vous prendz
attendez attendez mais il y en a j'en ai
tellement gouvernement ou pas bah
Dominique de Villepin je suis tellement
partagé j'ai à la fois une énorme
admiration pour lui pour d'une analyse
géopolitique et un courage géopolitique
et je pense
qu'il ne voit pas la France comme elle
est parce que ça fait longtemps qu'il
l'a quitté au sens qu'il ne vit plus au
milieu des Français vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est-à-dire qu'à la fois j'ai
de la sympathie pour lui et de
l'admiration pour son analyse
géopolitique mais qu'en même temps il a
toujours été très éloigné des Français
et je l'avais même expérimenté au moment
de l'affaire du CPE de 2006 c'est-à-dire
que je pense pas qu'on puisse incarner
la France si on regarde les Français
d'a-dessus et le général de Gaulle
n'était pas comme ça le général de
Gaulle était encré dans la terre de
France il payit sa facture d'électricité
oui non mais au-delà de ça oui bien sûr
mais au-delà de ça il était la France
Dominique de Villepin n'est pas ça quand
même ch lui reprocher
peut-être j'ai pas envie d'entrer
là-dedans parce qu'on pourrait reprocher
beaucoup de choses à tout le monde deè
livre mais deè livre ah j'ai un trou
parce que j'en tellement à vous donner
j'ai j'en ai un que j'ai sur le sinon
j'ai moi j'aime beaucoup
les oh je voudrais vous donner un livre
mais bien je vous laisse réfléchir je
vous pose une deuxième question quel est
le dernier on a un trou quel est le
dernier de film de science-fiction qui
vous a
émerveillé je suis pas très film de
science-fiction qu'est-ce que vous
pensez que plutôt drame psychologique en
couleur
quoi qu'est-ce que vous pensez que qu'
une team qui soit engagé par le
ministère de la Défense pour concevoir
des scénarios impensés ou impensa c'est
une bonne chose pas une bonne chose ça
c'est pas gênant il faut toujours
réfléchir à ce qui se passe faut
toujours imaginer le pire comment vous
analysez pas attendez mais ce que je
n'aime
pas c'est la manière dont on fait peur à
tout le monde vous savez le problème de
la des risques quand même faut pas ah
mais arrêter avec des risques oui il y a
des risques il y a des risques en
sortant d'ici je peux me faire renverser
par une trottinette il y a des risques
la vie est que le risque mais la vie
c'est la vie la vie c'est la prise de
risque un pays un pays qui a peur de
tout mais la peur n'écarte pas le danger
comme disait ma grand-mère tous nos
analystes nous nous ça vous paraît con
mais tous nos analystes ce censés
établir une vraie prospective ouais tous
ceux qu'on foir là ouais si vous êtes
président de la République vous faites
quoi vous les prenez tous vous les virez
vous les envoyez faire autre chose mais
de toute façon t ces G c'est des gens
qui parlent et pas qui font il faut des
gens qui font plus que des gens qui
parlent moi je suis terrien moi c'est
basique retrouver sa liberté agir en
fonction du bon sens développer le bien
commun de B mais deième bouquin je j'en
ai pas j'aiè bouquin j'ai trème bouquin
j'en ai pas j'en ai tellement que je
voudrais pas me j'ai la j'ai j'ai j'ai
mais c'est des romansisé en ce moment en
ce moment je dis lettre à ma fillole
d'un dénommé francheski un bouquin qu'
m'a offert pour mon anniversaire quand
le 7 mars un petit bouquin passionnant
de 24 lettres euh à sa fillole très
émouvant d'un homme franchis quii un nom
comme ça que je connaissais pas j'ai lu
aussi mais c'est pas les bouquins je
viens de lire aussi la République des
fauxoyeurs je vous en ai parlé parce que
ça m'a marqué
euh j'ai l un livre moi j'adorais Claude
Simon qui est un grand écrivain euh les
geéorgiques je sais pas si vous
connaissez c'est des Claude Simon c'est
des fresques extraordinaires euh voilà
je lis un peu de tout du Raymond hararon
j'ai Raymond hararon oui bien sûr est-ce
que vous avez un conseil les mémoire de
Raymond hararon je recommande à tout le
monde est-ce que vous avez un conseil
pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissable qui restera sur internet
avant la trisème guerre mondiale B
arrêtez n'ayez pas peur c'est le seul
mot n'ayez pas peur ce climat de peur
qui paralyse les gens qui les
infantilise
vous savez comment j'avais fait pour ma
dernière campagne en 2022 mais on l'a
fait personne l'a vu parce que ça était
un spot qu'on a mis à la fin il y avait
le spot télévisuel et vous savez les
spot du CSA là on fait notre petit topo
et à la fin j'ai eu l'idée j'ai dit on
éteint tout et on met le truc vous savez
quand on était gamin il y avait les ça
s'arrêtait quand il y avait une panne il
y avait marqué comme les interludes
voyez enfin je sais pas mire ouais une
espèce de mire et j'ai mis éteignez la
télé allumer vos cerveaux
et on l'a passé et vous savez que le CSA
à l'époque ça s'appelait le CSA ou
l'arcom a voulu bloquer en disant mais
monsieur dupoignant vous avez pas le
droit de mettre ça et j'aurais dit mais
qu'est-ce qui permet de l'interdire rien
et donc le mon dernier spot de 2
minutes je commence à parler et au bout
de 15 secondes ça s'arrête ça fait il y
a marqué éteignez la tulée allumez vos
cerveaux voilà c'était le message un peu
comme les guignoles de l'info avec vous
pouvez éteindre votre télé reprendre une
activité normale c'est ça oui voilà
c'était ça c'est tu avait dû être
inspiré par ça sans le savoir cétait du
gatio forcément
mais le problème des Français c'est ça
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on les a tellement
fait souffrir infantilisé
martyrisé et puis aussi c'est à eux de
se secouer c'est une stratégie du choc
oui bien sûr vous avez lu ce livre là
non je l'ai pas lu mais c'est c'est
archionnu d'ailleurs c'est la même
méthode si vous regardez c'est très
intéressant le choc un discours
hallucinant boum ensuite la télévisée
ensuite la
culpabilisation de non ensuite les
sondages 3ème étape 4è étape la
culpabilisation de ceux qui ne pensent
pas comme la majorité qui est décrite
dans les
sondages et puis voilà le tour est joué
et puis l'anéantissement et si 5è étape
l'anesthésie des oppositions qui
viennent vous voir pour vous dire mais
Nicolas tu as raison sur le fond mais tu
vas perdre ton électorat des personnes
âgées tu vas être battu dans sa c'est
vrai à la fin ils mont eu
tu vas perdre des voix parce que les
personnes âgées ne comprennent pas ton
message sur le covid ne comprennent pas
ton message sur l'Ukraine ne comprennent
pas ceci donc on fait le gros dos on
fait le dos rond et le seul truc
intéressant chez Trump qui m'a
réconforté c'est qu' un moment quand les
choses deviennent vraiment dangereuses
je pense qu'il faut y aller au contraire
au canon et dire au français voilà moi
je vais aller là est-ce que vous m'aimez
vous me suivez il y a pas d'autre
solution Nicolas merci merci à vous
[Musique]